I want to let you know that I have some
new tour dates to announce
Charlottesville VA on February
one uh Raleigh North Carolina February 2
Colombia South Carolina February 3 and
Knoxville Tennessee Go Big Orange on
February 4 at the Knoxville Coliseum as
well State College PA on February 7th
Syracuse New York February 8 and
Amhurst Massachusetts on February 9th
all tickets available at theo.
comom u r um don't buy through secondary
sites if the prices are jacked up just
wait we'll come on back through town but
uh looking forward to bringing the tour
near you thank you for the support
today's guests are two hit makers in the
uh country music Universe um one of them
is just named the best new artist at the
CMAs um one of them is one of the most
talented songwriters uh that there is um
they're Nashville guys and uh they are
friends of mine and they bring a lot of
joy to a lot of people I'm grateful to
have them both return to the podcast
today's guests are jelly roll and
[Music]
Ernest that
on I and tell you my
stories
sh on
me and I will find a song I will
[Applause]
sing I don't know why I just feel more
like yeah I put those on I think I'm
supposed to sing oh really does that
make sense it's like as soon as they go
on it's like check check can I get a
little Reverb yeah yeah I feel like when
I put them on I feel like I'm like I was
supposed to be do cold weather dude
because we
had oh in our neighborhood you'd have a
dude out there wearing uh yeah you
sometime you see like a ear muffs yeah
you'd have a dude wearing knees at
Christmas or something yeah that was the
um you're going to shoot your eye out
[__] why I'm so high camera mov story
yes they always wore those too yeah now
how high are you guys if you guys like
how high can you guys get well first of
all this is well we were just
the highest we've ever been is and we
did it with the same person but
separately yeah but I was sitting with
you gave us just enough time to get
stoned you know what I'm saying you were
like yo 10 minutes boys and me and
artist were like to the car look and I
was I was going to be 5 minutes the
Batmobile yeah I was going to be 5
minutes early but then you know we
pushed it so sorry so we might have
showed up sober for
the hey if somebody's like hey man we
gonna need five extra medicine here
that's when that's when the we sneaks
100% sitting here with jelly rolling
Ernest man thank you guys bro thank you
first of all thank you guys uh if you
don't mind while you're thinking us I
just want to start and I'm sure Ernest
wants to do this too is that as guys
that have been friends with you for a
while and my first podcast I ever did
was with you on Thanksgiving week by the
way as we sit here on Thanksgiving week
so I want to thank you for everything
you've done for me being early being a
Believer a supporter every time you've
ever said something nice about me but
more [__] importantly theovon
we want to give you your flowers you're
on [__] fire I don't know if you even
see it because you're such a humble iny
own head dude I know that is you as your
friend but you are [__] scorching it
has been so fun to watch Dude I mean it
is look at him blushing it was [__]
beautiful dog thanks so happy for you
man it was I was so glad to get the call
one just to get to hang out but two to
tell you in front of you and your
audience that
man I have never laughed as I've never I
mean I could just bore you with how
happy I am in every podcast I've watched
and just [__] how genius and
Brilliant you are but the Danel white
one most recently yeah dude I've watched
every Danel white scrum my whole career
right I got to where I don't even watch
the fights sometimes I just go Google
Dan White and see what the postcript
what did he say about the fights or they
[__] worth watching he'll tell the
truth there's a Chinese live feed you
can get of just him watching the fights
too really yeah but I uh dude i' never
heard him like that it was really cool
but I'm sorry I just I wanted to start
this and let you know we love you we're
happy for you we're here with the writer
of flower shops anyway so I think it's
they got to do it around dude what if
you did a you did a show where people
got their flowers from somebody like as
a g like as a you know thank you bro
that's really sweet retweet everything
he just said Thank you br well thank you
guys for making me laugh dude for making
me feel welcome in a new city you know I
will say that um you guys have been very
uh you showed up like the first time
that we had a show in um in Nashville at
zany man you came out and um and Ernest
you've been somebody that just you know
always you know checks in or cheers me
up or keeps me in the know what's going
on with a lot of these guys because so
many artists are on the road now and
stuff out of here you know um but thank
you bro very sweet of you man and happy
uh happy holidays boys happy holiday
Bubba praise God I was throwing Nu your
way for a second there my you got me
high man I got you and you guys wrote
tell me this cuz I didn't know this I
was at a uh riters round I think you
were performing that yep and you wrote
son of a center together yes sir wow
yeah that's crazy bro it is crazy it's
really crazy because him I believe son
of a sinner but then I get over here I'm
like hold on yeah well my my birth
father was definitely a sinner I was
adopted into a less of a sinning man oh
yeah then you're de yeah that's you're
like an aftermarket CER right I was I
was actually son of a deacon yeah son of
a deacon in the Church of Christ so we
actually have a song on his new album
that talks all about that actually oh my
goodness dude yeah so can I tell the
story yeah please dude so me and Luke
bran were playing golf out at trador and
we're listening to some rap and we
started talking about jelly roll he was
like y'all known each other for a while
a you I was like yeah we go back don't
act like you're not fighting your best
not to do your Luke Bryan impression
right
now hear it man I hear like uh you've
been known jelly roll ain't you that's
kind of bad it's kind of bad but but I
got a good one coming up here cuz I was
like yeah I I was like I used to uh I
used to go by his house and acquire some
things and we'd uh freestyle rap and
this is like back in 2010 I was like
then I went to college and he went to
jail and then we came back around all
these years later and Luke was like hold
up [__] you better write that
[__] song right now and so we start I
start kind of freestyling uh in the golf
cart it's like I went to college he went
to jail one was a dorm room one was a
cell who came out on top hell it's hard
to tell I went to college he went to
jail so we're going to tra that's the
only thing here so imagine this I'm
getting a FaceTime or a phone call like
every 16 minutes from a drunk Ernest and
a drunk Luke bran they drunk too Sun
beating on them they're sweating and
they're just like check this one out and
I'm like giving a little input here and
there and by about the fourth FaceTime I
was like these [__] are writing a
song on the golf course right now for
sure over FaceTime with no guitars wow
yeah that's crazy man I just have yeah I
guess inspiration can just kind of roll
up whenever huh is it is it as easy to
just go in a place and do inspiration
like that and get inspiration like if
you're sitting in a room with people or
is it is that a lot easier to find a way
to write a song or is it easier just if
you're Milling around with your boys it
can come both ways for sure I mean uh in
the right room inspiration is going to
be there um and just because you're out
you know having fun and living doesn't
mean that the inspiration is going to
hit you in that moment but I think I
think living breeds inspiration no
matter where you're at I'd like your
perspective from a comedian because as a
songwriter we're always writing songs
yeah right like whether we know it or
not subconsciously you might say
something here today that one of us will
grab and hit the other one with in a
text later like yo when Bubba said duh d
du there's a song There throw that in
the notes you know what I mean it's like
is it like that for y'all as well like
just in day-to-day life you're just
there's always there's there's always
you're always kind of writing a joke
whether you know it or not yeah I think
like if you're around your buddies
sometimes you get them to laugh you'll
write that down you know Rodney
Dangerfield was uh pretty famous he
would like um if he was on a shoot or
something he would in his off moments he
would get a uh get in a robe and and and
just hang out like when he wasn't
shooting like literally in a robe in
slippers I think cuz he felt real free
in it like his body felt free and he
would uh he would just write down he
would hang out by people and if
something was funny he would write it
down on a notepad and just keep it in
his pocket that's kind of like a famous
story that I heard I find if I'm like a
about say like the funniest times I ever
am is if like say if I if I was like
hanging out with a girl right and she
stayed over in the morning and I think
it's kind of the same thing if you drank
all night and you wake up in the morning
you're laughing like with your spouse or
something or with your spouse yeah and
you're kind of like having just that
that funny time right there that's my
fun I think that's when I feel like
that's your golden hour of Comedy it
really is yeah cuz if there's a if it's
a lady you're trying to impress there's
part of you that's always like lytically
trying to impress a lady I don't know if
it's limic or whatever but just damn
like Mediterranean or whatever that
Mediterranean part of your head is and
uh you're always just trying to impress
a lady so Mediterranean part of your
head whatever it is you know six extra
seconds for that to hit me but hey it
landed it
landed just moving but yeah I think
that's when I feel like I'm maybe my
most engaging or whatever it is with
because I think I as as as a a lot of
comedians are just trying to get a girl
to laugh really you don't have any way
to impress a woman that's what you
realize when you're young so you're like
I got to make somebody laugh or one of
these dudes is probably GNA [__] me you
know so it uh I gotta get funny quick I
relate as a fat person I always said
that uh you got to be a little humorous
and smell good you can't be fat stinky
and an [__] you can't be fat an
[__] and stin yeah you know what I'm
saying I just got to be fat you know
what I'm saying like that's it I got to
at least smell decent when I can and
better at least make somebody chuckle
every now and then you know yes yeah so
good dude and and I'll say to that too
um not even just girl but like an
audience like freestyling when we're
freestyling bro like if it's a car full
of people or a studio full of people and
the energy is room like that's that's
when I'm going to black out and be able
to Freestyle you know think and just
basically be channeling something
because I know I can see in real time
like what it's pulling out of people
like what do you mean oh so like if
you're doing like just in front of of
like a group or something yeah like you
can you can get a real real read on site
about whether this is cool or not
whereas like if it's just me by myself
with music or me and one other guy who's
you know so locked into his thing at the
time yeah then you can get in you can
get in your head and get in your own way
I feel like so I know it sounds weird
but if I had a choice to do it every
time I'd like treat it like a party and
us three would be writing a song but
we'd have the homies over there chilling
yeah you know what I'm saying like some
of our buddies cuz you can feel that
like just the energy of a room but yeah
it's always like it's also what you're
getting into a room writing's so fun
because there's I'm sure it's like this
for y'all but there's so many ways to do
it I've done it so many different ways
the now the most crazy way I've ever
seen it done and I sure you don't mind
me saying
this I had a session with Whiz Khalifa
the other night did you really listen
man whiz I don't get mad at me I don't
know what I'm supposed to tell this but
you [__] did it in front of me so
it's a fair game I think yeah he
recorded his verse
in
Reverse so I'm trying to figure out
what's happening cuz like I know it's
going to be hard to even explain and
keep in mind I've been smoking whiz for
like four hours at this point I'm cooked
I'm like what the [__] am I even doing I
feel like I'm taking shrooms or
something my Skin's crawling the room
you can't see through
it [__] like yo when your own skin
turns into a maze yeah the [__] you got
you can't even call the cops you need
literally need to call like the uh like
who Poison
Control call him poison control for sure
I I'll let you finish then I have a
poison control
story he would take the last bar and go
backwards so like he would be like and
I'm already gone and then he would go
back a measure and loop the beat a
measure into that and then figure out
what the line going into that was it was
the wildest [__] I've ever seen I'm not
bullshitting Earnest he did four bars
before I looked up and publicly said
loud is he recording this back backwards
like I had missed the whole he done it
for 15 minutes today it was crazy he
might be dyslexic there's not
a he's
verlex I mean you just describe dyslexia
and we're all like wonder what he's
doing you know like [__] hey that's
funny bro you don't see a lot of black
dyslexia either black dyslexia yeah yeah
you don't see it every day that's for
sure hey that's
funny that's great tell us about your
poison
let's go take a ride and get some QB bar
you know what I'm
saying bar you don't see a lot of black
down there at the way sub right now baby
I'll be home in a minute that's
hilarious we need more black dyslexia
out there huh dude's rapping like Yoda
it's insane dude I've never seen nothing
like it I was like and it was sick yeah
that's awesome dude if aliens show up
they better show up with some [__]
bars or the hoods going to be like [__]
these
[__] know what I'm saying D yes
yeah tough day to be a Square alien D
yeah yeah yeah cuz a lot of black people
have issues with aliens anyway bro a lot
of my dudes have told me that have
you've been hearing that a lot I've
heard stre not recently but I heard you
know I'm sure it hasn't changed from
since when I heard it yeah yeah probably
not if anything's probably gotten worse
yeah I don't think it was a me you know
I don't think it was a [__] meeting
oh my God but uh what was your story
Poison Control okay poison control this
are drugs involved in this not bad ones
okay honestly just Caff it's kind of
insane um so before one of these shows I
think we were at Marathon like two years
ago Maron is marathon music venue okay I
I probably weighed 50 pounds more than I
do right now just keep that in mind for
context I um was tired as hell I wasn't
drinking at the time so I went to the
gas station and got some caffeine pills
and it's like four pills in a thing and
I get back to the Green Room I take the
four pills and then and then read the
package
it was
like it's like you're supposed to just
take one of these you know you got four
deals that's a recommendation yeah well
so I I immed this is like 10 minutes
later I finally read the package I go
back in the bathroom make myself throw
up and like one empty capsule came out
in my puke and I was like oh boy and I'm
starting to get antsy and obviously
anxious about the whole scenario I don't
have the coolest heart on Earth and then
um I called Poison Control I was like no
brainer I'm must to see what I got to
say guy was like I was like hey man I
took four of these caffeine pills I feel
pretty uncomfortable right now I'm
sweating um it kind of hurts and he's
like oh man he's like yeah that's a lot
of caffeine he goes um but he was like
if you're in pretty good shape you
should be all right and I was like oh
all right thank you I hung up and I was
like [__] I'm not in that good of shape
now he's just he's [__] passive
aggressive if you're in pretty good
shape I think you should be all right
and I'm like what is pretty good shame
I'm definitely obese to an extent let me
draw a picture of myself I'll text it
over to you yeah so uh ended up being
totally uncomfortable and stayed up all
night and sweat but I survived Poison
Control dude yeah any and anytime you're
just casually calling Poison Control
dude that's a [__] weird yeah I'm
standing outside the venue kicking it
somebody probably just assumes I'm
talking to my mom or something I'm over
there am I going to die here in a minute
your PC what's good homie you know and
that's how I know you went to college
cuz I have never even thought to call
Poison Control at this moment I didn't I
didn't realize I thought that's
something you call when like you had
rats at the house yeah that's you would
just take two volumes and be like okay
exactly like this is it we'll take a
Xanax we'll defeat this We'll Fight Fire
with
Fire yeah dude me and my buddy went on a
date we were going to pick some girls up
for a date one time and we had just
taken these like no do pills remember
those o those are the first like drugs
for kids that came out like at a gas was
that like an over-the-counter
amphetamine basically yeah it was like
no do it said you could be a trucker you
know that's what it said on it right and
like
[__] I took a 5 Hour Energy drink one
time in my life and you still been up he
Ain and I took it I got off a plane this
was 10 years ago in Vegas and I rented a
car in Vegas to drive to LA because I
was so broke it was cheaper to fly into
Vegas and rent a car from there than fly
into La so I took and like I stopped at
one of them truck stops in the desert
yeah for sure one figure it
out one of them y we've all done those
in figs dud I'll get there 11 hours
later and I'll be on somebody's
shoulders and I took it dude and I'm
driving down the side of that you know
that old desert it's all Desert from
Vegas to LA and man it hit me dude and I
took the most squalling [__] on the side
of the road it was the most brutal
painful thing I've ever dealt with I
didn't sleep for a day yeah I'll never
take one again those things are po I
should have called Poison Control those
things are [__] evil we can't help
you what we call Poison Control and now
like what's up poison control we just
want to check in with you guys let you
know we're doing good yeah hey how how
are y'all how are you
doing nobody's ever calling a check on
y'all are y'all good over there you know
they have overdoses probably all the
time at you're definitely if you have to
work at a call center dude in India
you're definitely using a lot of pills
probably to stay up oh yeah Indian dudes
they got well they got a lot in their
system though man a lot of Indian dudes
we had an Indian dude a lot of Indian
they they have like a lot more spices
you know [__] that's the B oh they a lot
of Indian dudes you'll smell you know if
they was by the house you'll know they
was by the house you know yeah hell yeah
the dog will come right up on them you
know hone do you hear that no but I
smell that I think the Indians just got
yeah dude cuz Indian people eat a lot of
spicy food and just comes out their
pores you know it's like being around an
alcoholic but yes it's like yeah a lot
of Indian dudes their their arteries are
it's just like a halfway house for like
a spice rack you
know a lot of [__] got that
coriander in them you know yes yeah dude
um Steph Curry oh dude Steph Curry what
if he made a restaurant called Steph
Curry it would do well I'm sure it would
do well they had 30 different things on
the menu yeah I a great idea D already
open it though San
Francisco Steph's Steph's Curry Steph's
curry curry sounds like a uh or Steph
Curry's Steph Curry's Steph Curry sounds
like a steakouse a little bit Steph's
Curry sounds like a kind of a like a
girl's uh STD yeah you know what I'm
saying yeah it sound like some it sound
like some like like almost like vaginal
witchcraft you know vaginal witchcraft
yes you got to get a hit of Steph Curry
like I'm
good it sounds like a dude in prison
that tries to pretend like his butt is a
vagina you know like oh I'm going get
some of this Steph's Curry you know
sobach b sobach b throwing out that that
Steph's Curry all afternoon oh they
sering warm Stu's Curry over there in
that buy did you get high with us before
we got
it oh I live VI cariously through High
people I wish all had smoked in here
dude would have I can't smoke but I can
do but I can I don't think there's
anything says you can second second yeah
you can smell it dude I wanted to open
up a shoe store by um walking Phoenix
called These Boots Were Made for Walking
like
near that's like one of the dumbest
ideas his only shoes that he could fit
in too like if you fit in these we got
the boot for you yeah he'd have to stop
if you're driving out of your house and
you see the shop near you like [__] got
to go These boots are made for walking
is I got to stop how was
um how was the CMAs man you guys got to
go dude congratulations too man and did
you yeah congratulations than Best New
Artist was it huh yes sir it was crazy
man it was it was really interesting cuz
I didn't think I had a chance to win it
really yeah man I mean that true you
didn't think get all I did not at all
who you up against I was up against Zack
Bryan and Parker McCullum right and I
felt like no all pun intended to my boy
I felt like Parker had a hell of a year
and I feel like Zach Bryan is the second
most streamed artist in country music
right now behind Morgan so it's like it
to me it was a no-brainer and I'm such a
Zach Bryan fan like so the fact that I
got to sit next to him the whole night
like it's so funny we glad to too yeah
that was cool for me and him to get that
moment cuz he was awesome dud I there
was a moment where I literally felt like
me and him were like tailgating and
watching a concert outside of an arena
yeah you know like he's over there
drinking I'm ripping a weed pin you know
what I'm saying he's cracking beers
there's empty shot
glasses there's empty shot glasses under
my seat he's got four or five half
drinking drinks under his every keeps
bringing him drinks and we're just there
talking about the music all night and I
just thought for sure he would win you
know the last thing right before they
announced the name was I think I tapped
him on a shoulder and said say something
nice about me or something funny you
know oh that's cool and then whenever I
uh uh I hugged him going up there I was
like man you you you deserve this you
know what I mean and then you looked at
him like don't worry I'll say something
ni I can do it now don't worry but it
was so it was really cool and I had
you've had this a lot in your career but
I was blessed for the first time in my
career to have a real viral moment like
I thought I'd went viral before but it
was like just building to a real viral
moment like for whatever reason and I
didn't touch my phone for like 36 hours
after the award show because it was just
such a big moment I was just letting it
sit you know and I didn't want to have
my phone on me that night and everybody
kept telling me man you're going viral
and I was like I'm you know I'm like oh
cool I'm thinking check your bracelet to
see if your doctor's letting you
know I'm more concerned with [__]
ain't a
whoop that's a that's a what that a a
whoop on that boy
I wor whoop this whole tour Believe It
or Not l 50 PBS on tour yeah in I marked
my sleep every night I checked my show
my show was like a work you have been
living well dude tell I've never live
dude it was awesome but i i d I wore my
whoop forever you got to be careful yeah
you don't want to have to get yeah
because I guess also if you're a bigger
guy you just have to be careful like
yeah like uh stavos uh hus um was just
in here I love stavy oh y he's so
[__] funny he is so funny dude and he
uh but he was talking about what it's
like being bigger he's like it's fun to
be big you just have to also manage it
you can't get over big yeah so you just
gotta make you you just have to enjoy
your big but you can't [__] you know
you can't be like I'm gonna you know get
just extra big cuz I can yeah yeah for
sure no what there's the point where it
starts [__] yeah let me let I had
that recently like let me pull the rains
back dial this back get a surgery best
new
artery too much
best sorry man that
uh but so that was so wild and then they
was it really like you were just shocked
I was really shocked I really didn't
have a uh I didn't have a plan walking
up there I was just walking up there
like man I didn't you know I was I was
getting more excited as I was getting up
there adrenaline's pumping I'm in the
[__] brid Stone Arena I'm on National
Television dude I'm still a white trash
kid from Antioch all this is like what
the [__] is going on you know what I'm
saying like it I'm not I'm not jaded to
this there's I'm not used to this at
this point in my career I'm still like
this is wow
you know and I'm standing up there and
I'm how many steps is it up there like
how high is that how how is the St it's
like a dude I didn't walk it but I bet
it's like 10 steps I tell you I didn't
feel them wow I was on the cloud Bubba
you know at that moment you're just like
man this is you know that would be the
scariest step because then you know once
you get up there you have to turn around
and say something that would be what was
so scary no no I was just more like you
murdered that speech yeah I was just
walking up there like thinking of my I
was I don't know what I was thinking I
was thinking like I tell you when I
started thinking was when I looked up
and this is inside baseball I like I
have the award I raise it up and I look
straight up and there's a teleprompter
that's going I'm not [__] you Theo
59 58 57 and I think to myself I got a
lot to say and a little time to do it I
didn't realized till I watched the
speech afterwards that I actually said
that out loud in that moment I was like
I got a lot of things to say and I'm gon
to say it really quick huh but that was
me thinking out loud because I remember
thinking that that's the first time I
remember really thinking in that moment
was like oh [__] this is real got 58
seconds where they're going to start
playing the music on me and they're
going to send a Sandman from Apollo and
pull me I was like I better make this
count you know what I'm saying I knew in
that moment too I was like I'm
definitely not winning another award
tonight for
sure I'm G say it all right now I
definitely didn't think I was going to
win this one yeah you know yeah I just
[__] fired dude it was the coolest
thing AR that's so cool you're on a
rocket ship bro dude it was it's funny I
wouldn't think of any y as new artists
though in a weird way but that that
doesn't matter it's just it's like a
Accolade they do it doesn't really
matter what it is it's like saying hey
man uh people recognize you and they see
exactly right it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter how long people people
have been winning that award that have
been around for a while but it is like
you on the map we recognize you see you
it's your time yeah and it is so I mean
I was giving you flowers out there but
it is true I mean everybody sees it that
it's just the lights are turned on for
you right now all the lights are on for
you right now and I'm so stoked because
you do um and I've told you this before
you do such a good job with your Podium
that you're on and giving back to this
city and U and and the things that built
you and it's just I love knowing you as
a fellow nashvillian it's just Nashville
is very well represented thank you for
no it means a lot to me coming from
y'all especially but you guys are really
the you know some of the roots I know
there's a lot of guys around this area
you know yeah but you guys are uh people
that if I mention like to people I'm
like at the gym with or something
there's always somebody that knows one
of you guys you know some of the guys
that knew you weren't usually doing too
well I'll say that but uh but they're
good guys you know good
guys hey that's funny true [__]
methodin let's go boy if you came out
with a [__] suboxin or a methadone
that would be jelly jelly donut flavored
suboxin for sure a fourth will get you
by yeah Subway sub box
in
subbox yeah just the subway branding but
subbox in somebody make that shirt bro
that is got to be a at least a painting
to put in this room
sub I just I walked in here thinking I'm
having the biggest week of my career and
they're going to get me in trouble and I
was right knew it dude I knew it if
you're low on time you can make the
hours you've got a hold lot happier with
dash pass from door dash dash pass is
the one membership you need to get the
most out of door Dash and everyday life
dash pass members get Z delivery fees
and up to 10% off eligible door Dash
orders including groceries drinks
Personal Care items and more plus dash
pass delivers way more than just
tonight's dinner including special
access to experiences promotions and
dash pass exclusive menu items all for
only $9.99 a month put a little Joy back
into your schedule sign up for dash pass
today use code Theo 23 and get 50% off
up to a $10 value when you spend $12 or
more after signing up for dash pass
that's right subject to change terms
apply blue chew baby you need them get
them I pop one to dude if I'm I go I'm
going any I'm going anywhere I pop one
and eat half a thing of Dipping Dots
baby that's me bluechew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra Calis and
Levitra but in chew able tablets and at
a fraction of the cost that's right blue
Cho's tablets are made in the USA boy
and presented and Shi direct to your
door in a discret package blue wants to
help you have better X discover your
options at bluechew.com just chew it and
do
it and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try blueo free when you use
our promo code Theo at checkout just pay
$5 shipping that's B
cw.com promo code Theo to receive your
first month free visit bluechew.com for
more details and important safety
information and we thank blue for
sponsoring the podcast you know you
shouldn't get stuck worrying about
shipping orders this holiday season
that's Santa's job isn't it that's his
job but ship station they'll do it for
you that's right they'll do the heavy
lifting so you or your team can put your
time money and energy in a more
important things plus when it comes to
those inevitable holiday returns ship
station automates recommends exchanges
and gathers customer feedback so even if
they bought the wrong size or color or
item they'll still have a great
experience that's right ship station is
so easy to use it has effortless
integration everywhere you sell online
including Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify and
more let your customers shop risk free
this holiday season with shipstation go
to
shipstation.com and use code Theo today
and sign up for your free 60-day trial
that's sh P St a Tio n
. code Theo is it weird like because
yeah thinking about that kind of stuff
do you start to feel more like you have
to be um wait did and did you get any
songwriting Awards this year I know you
got did you win any CMAs or no uh no
CMAs no okay sorry is that weird to say
I know you want I know you want a ton of
hell no I went it was like a date night
and I got to sit and cheer my friends on
yeah Ernest got drunk let me tell you
what happened time er every time Ernest
walked by me at the CMAs he was I was
bringing Zack a drink each time I came
back too well who was the other three
for Ernest me my me and me and Delaney
he would he would look like a bartender
he would have two drinks in each hand
well they ought to have somebody doing
that for us so Parker McCullum was like
at every time I seen him one he'd have
him and his wife one and every time he's
just walking by it's for safety measures
though CU you don't know how long you're
going to have to sit like it might be
the last chance you ever get to get a
drink you're waiting for a commercial
break like a drug addict I swear bro
you're waiting for it like Chow in
prison you're sitting there and you're
just waiting I don't know what that's
like Chow it's a new Chinese
inmate who's getting this
cutie and you're just sitting there and
they're like commercial break and you're
just like you just watch everybody stand
up yeah and just immediately start
shuffling really is it like it's like
when school it's like recess at school
it's like it's like when the bell rings
and you got five minutes to get between
classes yeah it's funny how I went to a
jail reference before I thought of
school [__] well that's it you went to
you went to jail I went to college oh
it's the song again it's exactly the
song that's so funny man I think but
back to the Nashville thing Theo I think
that's what made it so beautiful that my
first number one was written with Ernest
and keep in mind that we're already like
Ernest is on his seventh or eighth
number one at that point in his career
and I'm calling him now we're looking at
a decade plus of real friendship so I'm
calling Earnest and I'm like saying it
you know how I talk I'm people y'all
know how y'all see me on here is how I
am my friends are test I'm a very
straightforward like hey I need help can
you I call Ernest like uh the first time
I got on Theo and Brennan's podcast I
hit him like yo I really need this this
is a good look for me they were like
come on but same thing with busting with
the boys but I call Ernest I'm like
Bubba I'm treading new water here come
over here and drop some of that sauce
off wow you know what I was saying I was
like [__] with your boy man you know
what I mean I'm like it's just me and my
dude me and my dude that wrote save me
we're friends of 20 something years yeah
he's from a trailer park Nashville grew
up piss poor never neither one of us
dreamed of being songwriters we just
dreamed of not being drug dealers yeah
you know and um so we're just in there
pilling around and we're like we don't
really we can't even read yeah sure I'm
like we're not qualified to try offense
D don't know the guy exactly I'm like
middle I'm like we're not qualified to
write a radio song by ourselves you know
what I'm saying I was like I only know
one person we going to write this song
we can't even read there's only one hit
writer in town that'll take my call let
me call him yo er do me a favor pull up
he's like I got you are you there all
week I'm like I'm here all week and
we've told the story but he was going to
get ribs and next door at the barbecue
pit he really just came
to so Earnest that's Earnest is that
good he's like you know what I got to
pick up some ribs in about an hour but
I'll stop while they were smoking he
came in he was like I got like 30
minutes to kill or something Fu exactly
whated he wrote a piece of the song he
he just like poured out an idea I was
like love y'all let me know how goes I I
looked at our text thread after it went
number one because that night I texted
Ernest at like 4 in the morning cuz I
was up you sent back a demo a demo at 4
in the morning I was like we might we
might actually have something here yeah
and then then so good when I left like
is we had the son longest son of a c and
like that [__] was just tattooed in my
brain from the second I left until till
now and then I had to double back with
the favor Theo because then when we get
the song done I'm like well [__] we
don't know nobody to produce a radio
song neither right so I call Ernest I'm
like you gotta produce called him back
hey I'm I'm one for one on producing
country songs and then going to the top
baby that your first produced one yeah
it's the only thing I produced the best
part was I I had to gas him up the yo he
was like the Rudy rud
girlally One play one sack that's me I
had to gas him up bro I had to be like
yo man you can do this he was like I've
never done it I was like I definitely
can't do it if we have to pick right now
who's the most qualified to do it it's
[__] you man you got to figure it out
he was like all right man [__] I'll
figure it out I was like all right cool
wow crazy that is crazy hearing it out
loud again though cuz you know I almost
had to bully him into it the I was like
you got this I I felt impostor syndrome
being around you know the producer all
the time but uh singing that song it's
in my set every night and I I love it
like one of mine like because uh and I
say every night I give a brief overcap
of knowing him and then how special it
is that one's that's all the time when
people ask me what my favorite number
one is it's that one because of that
reason because it's homegrown 100%
homegrown three Nashville dudes three
Nashville dudes that 10 years before you
could have never told us we would be hit
song writers any of us you know what I
mean so and we put real real real stuff
in a song vulnerable that country radio
accepted yeah and like that's cool like
pills and you know addiction and weird
lingo that most country songs don't have
yeah well nowadays that's your dog in
your truck dude if you don't you know
what I'm saying if you if you dog the
dog Chucks on blocks Chu on blocking
we're moved on we're moving on to
obus the genre has evolved no man I
remember cuz I was at I went to the
Opera and I saw you and um performing
and then you played that song I was like
I just didn't know I didn't know the
that's where it was that was that was
when it was and I was like wow cuz I
just love listening to that song man you
know what you did me a solid Theo the
holler it's a big country themed um
YouTube social media site and they did
like one of them 30- second things with
you and they said what's a country song
you can listen to Non-Stop and you said
Son of a sinner by jelly roll and you
said no never mind Save Me by jelly roll
oh nice thank
you you threw me a big alley cuz that
[__] cuz you did it it went Boll
everybody s that to me I like I love
where you at right now where you at with
Laney on that we're number two we're
number two yeah we should be pushing
next week Sav me should be the number
one song on country radio whenever this
comes by the time this comes out it
should I should be able to say this
number I'm a Jessie Mur I I'm a Jesse
murf fan too I've been a Jessie Mur fan
for so good feels scary even saying it
cuz she's like a young girl you know but
it's like you can f I am a I know all of
her songs dude which is really alarming
to say and I might even I don't want to
hear this I'm glad I'm not I can't hear
that good if it makes you feel better
you if you were like me I heard the
voice before I seen her and nothing
about her voice says she's a 19-year-old
girl right like her voice says she's a
37 year old woman that's been through a
lifetime of pain and anger you know what
I'm saying it's like when you hear just
the voice cuz I just heard the music
like and then I found out who it was
yeah and then I was like oh this is dope
but she's You' love her man she's like a
little sister man she's like I got to
meet up with her one night her and this
guy Shay know uh he's like a
light-skinned dude dude he writes music
Shai sh sh Carter yeah sorry sorry yeah
yeah Shai Carter yeah dude it was
awesome I got to meet up with them and
uh in in Los Angeles and just I was a Hu
I was a huge fan of hers and then her
manager I think Ben knew about it and
he's like oh uh Jesse's in town if you
want to stop by and get to say hey and
so I got to stop by and meet them sick
God awesome and this and like she played
some of her new music and stuff it's so
good man yeah she don't miss baby while
you're at it yeah why don't you rap I
need to tap in I I only know like bro
once you get on it though dude her Tik
Tok [__] is so V like once you get on it
it's like you're it's like you it'll be
weird because you'll just be like at the
CVS or something and you're just
standing there by yourself singing
Jessie murf and these kids start looking
at you like this guy's a pervert get
this guy out of here but he's a pervert
that listens to good music isn't he
pervert true good taste absolutely that
was the funny part when they sent me
wild ones I was
like somebody suggested like you should
do a verse on Wild Ones and I was like
yeah yeah I'm going to sing about my
wife though like I'm not getting on any
song with a young woman and not talk
about the most important woman in my
life they were like cool I was like
whatever as long as the label don't trip
on my verse cuz I sent a verse in just
like not think I thought they were
rejected cuz I'm talking like [__] a
little bit right you know what I'm
saying I was like they're not going to
let me flat and they were like this is
it I was like [__] let's go so far
yeah it was so good bunny is my what's
that line Bunny's my Harley Quin yeah
you know what I'm saying fun getting
back to getting to the freedom of having
a getting a rap verse oh dude it's like
it feels so I've been in a situation
lately where I've got to go write a
bunch of stuff by myself or like in two
ways again like save me or you know what
I mean like that style and it's been a
ball which we should do I've pulled up
to a lot of places and just been thrown
into like a feature category again when
they're just like well just write
something for this and I'm just like
hell yeah good stuff yeah it's normally
like we write in like twos or threes cuz
it's easier to bounce ideas off each
other that way and uh but like when you
go do a feature for somebody especially
in the hip-hop world they just you just
got a beat and you're just like writing
something and you're like by yourself
again it's the coolest most dangerous
thing ever because you go back to what
you think's cool y you know what I mean
it's like I don't give a [__] what
nobody thinks I'm wigging out about this
I think this is sick I'm in my little
I'm I'm on my kitchen T I still write
the kitchen table like I did when I was
a kid I got my little headphones all my
wife's out there and then finally I'll
be like come check this out you're pined
the pad too right yeah I'm still pin the
pad I'm still old school I love that I
can't well because [__] I also don't
know how to play the music and go to my
notes at the same time on my phone my
hand don't work fast enough like if when
I try writing a it's either illegible
because is that how you pronounce that
yeah or something illegible yeah yeah my
handwriting so bad because I'm trying to
write so fast cuz my thoughts and like
I'm afraid I'll forget it by the time I
get done I've never seen you write
anyways though you've never I've never
seen you be the scbe in the room nobody
believes you write anything and people
just believe you just show up yeah
literally i' I've never
WR falls out of you dude name one time
you've been the guy with the laptop type
in the [__] lyrics arest never the
guy with the laptop but I sometimes I I
do write complete ideas in my notes on
my phone and then bring it with and put
a guitar to it but often It Is Just Like
Music somebody get a voice note going
blah somebody type that out yeah yeah I
need to scribes what's that line I
remember seeing you get so excited about
it's like uh map dot oh a oh Hardy said
that ain't that a map. shame he said in
more than my hometown ain't that a map
do shame and think that yeah I mean I
added nothing to that song that night
other than the room we wrote it in and
then when he said that I about ran
through a glass wall I was so I remember
you saying one time fired up how so
excited you were about that lyric I
don't know I mean it caught me off guard
ain't that a map dot ain't that a map
dot Shan ain't that a map dot Shan yeah
so good that's such a cool way I like
that's that lyric uh well I got I took
some pills she took the dogs all it's
all that's a hell of a she's gone to her
mom god dude and I took up drinking
since she took the time to tell me I
took the best years of her life God sad
it is sad man sad songs make me happy
yeah I wonder if uh if people relate
more now to sad is do you think the
overall that music's sadder or different
than it was when we were like growing up
and you and I are probably more closer
to age in nnest but like I just wonder
sometimes you know I think so I think is
there more s music think there's more
real auth more vulnerability okay there
you go it was so curated so music used
to be curated there was it was the
labels were in the power and they would
curate songwriters they would pick the
songs they would make the artists record
the songs this like it was a big deal
when artists got to start picking their
own songs in this town there was time
where like label was were like this is
your song I called it I get in trouble
every time I do this by the way but [__]
it I called it the Build-A-Bear system
right like Nashville was like build a
bear like they would find a bear they
would put cowboy hat on bear cowboy
boots on bear they would give bear a
song Give bear a guitar make bear have a
band of bears behind bear put bear on
tour put bear on radio and it was
completely like they were these dudes
were like [__] robots they were
Muppets right you know what I mean for
the the system and the power and what
we've seen in light of the internet and
I always compare stuff to like other
things for connectivity and comedy we've
seen it as well right in podcasting and
and the the ability to y'all to go
direct to Consumer right like like the
idea that a guy like Zack Bryan can be
writing songs in the military and sets
up his phone and just sweating just
singing his ass off and can connect with
people with with no in between right Y
and that's why sometimes establishment
don't like him because they had
absolutely nothing to do with his
success but we've gotten to a place
where like we're back this the last time
this really happened and somebody's
going to argue with me but [__] them was
in the 60s and the 70s the singer
songwriter movement yeah right where you
would see guys that were like writing
their own songs and singing their own
songs Willie Nelson whan Dylan James
Taylor The Outlaws but I mean it it went
over like I was playing a you know
Jackson Free have you wrote with him yet
oh yeah he's a I love that kid I think I
think he's gonna be he's 23 in the next
10 15 years remember we said this name
Theo this kid's going to have 30 40
number one Jackson freeon Jackson free
spells it with an X but he didn't
realize how deep Dylan's catalog was
because like if you're like I don't know
if do you ever get into Dylan Bob Dylan
Bob Dylan yeah no so the was it the
nasal thing that threw you off I don't
remember I just don't know if I I I just
don't remember him that good but it's
like you've heard some of his songs
without knowing right heart is that him
uh sounds like
Tom yeah
like man I don't know if that did in the
basement mixing up the medicine I'm on
the P about the government yeah I think
wow Bob Dyan was kind of rapping but he
also wrote Along the Watchtower yes
right like he like and Jackson didn't
realize his and I'm playing them all
these big records I'm like you know 10
Bob Dylan songs I could do it for you
right now where you're like no I don't
I'm like I play them you're like oh [__]
I do know 10 Bob Dylan songs I just know
didn't know Bob Dylan wrote them yeah
because but it was a different era these
guys were like writing their own songs
and singing them and then we went
through the 20 30y year curated space
uhuh and now it's like there's a lot of
guys that are singing their own stories
again and that's why I think the
connectivity is different and I think
the vulnerability shows because it's
just men being honest in their music so
it might seem a little sadder but I
think it's just more more authentic yeah
that's a good that's a great answer yeah
I agree with that for sure Jesus Christ
that's a good answer thank you bro same
to say with the music too more like not
even just the lyrics
like I don't know pop was so synthesized
it feels like synthetic would be the
word but like now real instruments and
like not being so on the grid when I say
on the grid like a protool session
literally locked in on the grid guys
like Zach playing how it feels more so
than just everything's got to be perfect
yes and like that just opens up a yard
for people that are willing to do it you
know kind of break the mold and go play
in that yard and that's like yeah sad
songs are going to happen in there I
love steel guitar steel guitar is all
over my record and there's not a sadder
sounding instrument than steel guitar so
I consciously write a lot of times to
cater to steel guitar like I you know I
think that to give you your flowers
though outside of the genius you are as
a songwriter as the artist Earnest
that's what makes you special though
Bubba is like you focus not only on the
top line and the lyric there's a sound
that you want you're bringing like
you're years ahead of your time with
bringing that sound back around just
like Hardy was years ahead of his time
with bringing in the really rock heavy
metal country it's like guys like that
is when you think about the guys who
really went on to win it's because their
sound was so different as well not just
the [__] that were singing about like
the like when I see an Earnest show it's
like nostalgic it's like this but with
new Concepts written over the top of
this super old nostalgic sound you know
what I mean it's just really sick to me
and it's the same thing I hear when I
hear Hardy like listen I bang truck bed
like me and Bunny are beefing and me and
her we don't argue at all that's my best
friend you know what I mean I love my
wife we don't have any problems but I
still wake up bang truck bed like I'm
[__] ready to get divorced you know
what I'm saying like that song Just
[__] in every way and it's because it
breaks every rule in Nashville oh yeah
not just Nashville but every rule in
like he said there's a system in music
Theo that's like okay and he knows the
number system better than me he'll
explain this I the
number yeah it's like so okay I did
here's the one I got to go to the four
cuz that's what supposed to happen next
it's like can't you go to the five it's
like nope got to go to the four like
[__] you go to the five you know what
I'm saying it's like you know yeah well
yeah I think there's an overall system
in the world like that that that that
kind of like you know the powers of be
kind of feel like they they've got
everything down to an algorithm but I
think it's it's again proof that uh that
originality and hu that there's
something inside of us that wants to be
original not just individually but even
as a species where it's like we don't
you know don't confine everything into
that space you can't lock us into an
algorithm as humans you know like we're
going to find a way out of it you know
and I think that's one thing that's
great about a lot of the music right now
say like yeah even some of the artists
when you're saying who is even up for
Best New Artist At I don't even know if
I would say half those people are
country you know I wouldn't put them
just as a country music you know like
it's good that's a great term yeah yeah
but it's like Zack Bryant I'm to me it's
like he's a some people could say he's
their Bob Dylan you know like yeah he is
yeah genres are totally scared right now
yeah like Jesse Murphy's she's in seven
genres yeah for sure you know it's like
um jelly it's like most people if You'
have said 10 years is he is he a a
country it's like he's a country
[__] you know in the sense that
you know like he definit all things are
true for him in when he's rapping when
he's singing country songs or rock songs
the story never story the story is the
same it's just a matter what furniture
you're dressing a room with and the
story needed stop it Ernest yeah clip
that got clip that for me somebody say
again I was saying the story stays the
same to matter the genre the furniture
changes in which you're decorating your
room with damn bro that's [__] hard I
needed thank you brother yeah I needed
that but but I'm country I want out
first of all I love country music like
as a fan like I'm obsessed with country
music have been my whole life and
because being from this town I was
always fascinated with when I was a kid
there was no other job in this town like
you were either you know like a a Layman
or a bartender or you worked in country
music somehow right yeah for sure yeah
100% it's like you know and my mother
was a bartender so she took like great
pride in like this like the country
music scene being in this town and
coming to the bars and like it was like
I remember CMA week would come uh fanf
fair is what they called it back then
and it would be like an economic shift
like our families would plan vacations
around it like all right well we can't
go to July cuz fanf fair is in June and
we gonna have the money then they put
back Christmas money because it was such
this town only had 300,000 people in it
there so you got to think we're bringing
an extra 50,000 people to town for
Fanfare it was like a six of our
population a fifth of our population was
just showing up to spend money in one
week the bartenders celebr they called
it hell week they were like this is
going to suck but we're all going to get
b rolls you know what I'm saying like
don't worry we're eating steak on Friday
baby you know what I'm saying we're
going to afford that divorce next
Monday that's got to be the worst you
can't get wor because you can't afford
it it's like a Fu you IM just waking up
every day like I would leave you if I I
financially if I had $640 I'd Le your
ass
foul right now bu a dollar for every
time I've heard you say it I'd leave you
yeah I'm surprised I haven't seen more
gofundmes about divorces like just
looking for $1,000 to foul that's
hilarious that'd be a great reality
Marketplace they want three grand to get
a
new that's so dude the crazy thing about
touring is you to you're like uh you
meet people like oh we're from dipp and
Dot Alabama and you're like where the
[__] is that where is that oh I'm from
uh mix breed Arkansas you're like what
where did you see that video about the
most racist town in America being in
Arkansas and the guy from I can't
remember I shouldn't I'm too high to
talk about this might have been Eric
Andre maybe who went to no no no it was
it's a you it's a famous YouTuber I
follow his channel I'm just [__]
can't remember his name right now the
black dude went into it was trying to
interview the guy yeah he
was no it was somebody else I can't
remember dude's name but I've seen can't
remember his name he's got he's got
dreads and he he went to like Alaska he
always goes to weird places but it was
[__] super cool too super cool he
went he wore like a trump shirt or
something yeah and he went to the most
racist town in the you would Theo you
would piss yourself I know your person
to for the most part people were trying
to be pretty nice and like be like hey
do you know kind of you know where
you're at you know he'd be knocking on
the door or something and you know an
older white couple would come out and be
like oh hey like you shouldn't you
probably shouldn't be in this town likey
like fair warning not like we're going
to do anything but I can't speak for my
neighbors they're like oh you should you
shouldn't be out after dark I mean you
shouldn't be out
dark yeah either both yeah yeah but no
dude handled it like a champ and he was
obviously knew he was going into the
fire but it's like it's good content
yeah he he he talked to one old
toothless man boy and I cry I pissed
myself it was so funny yeah one of my
favorite videos I've ever seen in my
life yeah I think you should have if you
want to be racist I think you should at
least have to have all your teeth I feel
like like right cuz otherwise you're not
even taking care of your end of the you
know it's like you should at least have
to fix yourself
up who are you there should be a
criteria there should be a criteria for
RAC for a guy who doesn't like blacks
you have a black space in your smile
okay which is really interesting that
you'd let a nice white tooth expire okay
kind of hypocritical talk you and your
interracial Grand over there oh my God
that's crazy dude if you got hair you
want to keep it that's it so unless you
don't but most of you do and if you do
then you're like me I'm keeping mine
around keeps is an online subscription
service that makes it easy and more
affordable for men to treat their male
pattern baldness from the comfort of
their home with keeps you get clinically
proven treatments to address hair loss
and boost hair regrowth delivered right
to your door complete compl an online
consultation to get matched with a
treatment plan tailored to address your
hair loss concerns find a plan that
works for your schedule with the
flexibility of three six and 12 month
delivery options that's right plus you
can adjust pause or cancel your plan at
any time I recommend if you do get going
on a plan stick with it I uh I've done
that and I'm keeping my hair I'm pretty
stoked about that to be
honest hair loss stops with keeps for a
special offer to get started go to ke
ps.com
Theo or click the link in the
description that's ke ps.com
o i was an offender bner once I was uh
using drugs and uh couple little ladies
did a u-turn and uh and hit me they hit
me and they ran off both of them couple
thoughts but don't matter boy that's
life Morgan and Morgan is America's
largest injury injury Law Firm they have
over 100 offices Nationwide and more
than 800 lawyers they can help you
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan is so easy it's more like
using an app than hiring a lawyer in
eight clicks or less you can submit a
claim to Morgan and Morgan if you've
ever been injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win for more information go
to forthepeople.com
[Music]
slis past weekend or dial pound law
which is pound 529 from your cell phone
that's
forthepeople.com
this past weekend or dial pound law
pound 529 from your cell this is a paid
advertisement this episode is sponsored
by better help that's right I've
struggled mentally hell you know it I
mean look at the first well look at most
of this podcast
better help was there for me when I
needed it I need some help I tried
better help that's it better help can
match you with a licensed clinical
professional therapist so if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapist at any time for no additional
charge I re commend if you don't think
the therapist you're with is helping you
you may like going to them it may be fun
it may be easy if it's not helping you
then I recommend that you switch that's
something I had to learn from myself in
the season of giving give yourself what
you need with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com
today to get 10% off your first month
that's better
HP betterhelp.com
Theo but yeah I it's I I think what
what's happening with guys like there's
always kind of like guys that come along
and evolve this thing and I think it
also is an evolution of what men like
it's not just the dog and the truck you
know some of those old like um what are
those things called eupan isms
e that's killing it all euthanization
isms oh
yeah yeah analogies met tropes something
like that but I think those are even
evolving it's like a man is a what you
know it's like now a guy is sitting on
Horseback but he's playing Nintendo
switch you know yeah the furniture's
changed right the furniture Chang Chang
but but it is cool it it like I was
saying about there being a fresh yard to
play in as a writer um it is way more
freeing to write songs now than it was
when I first started writing songs and I
think part of that is with some success
comes more freedom to get to do it but
like yeah like you know the options of
guys that will cut songs now are is
different like you know you got he's
willing to say way more [__] than so and
so is willing to say or like um you know
if post is coming wants to make country
songs like there's an option for like
you really got some more freedom to say
stuff that you know so and so over here
would never say or never even be able to
say that has a little more swag or a
little more sauce on it right and that
for guys like me I love that because
then then I really get to exercise
the fun muscle in my brain that's true
when artists start to like collab and
stuff it's like anything could kind of
be H could kind of happen and then you
still have guys like John party that's
kind of like fun Tre you know like yeah
and writing for a guy like that is so
much fun too because then you get to
step into like a honky tonk world and
you know you oh this sounds like a party
thing that's the greatest compliment you
can play pay an artist in life is when
you're thinking of something and you're
thinking of a song in your head and
you're like man that's a that's a more
of a party record like that shows how
much of a brand he's built with the spec
like spec how do you say spec specific
don't hurt yourself sorry [__] I'm
blowing it like speciic yeah like he's
so specific and what how why did it take
me that long to get just you
Theo need some Naran over
here only you have to hit jelly with
some Naran get a word out of
him dude that'd be crazy imagine if and
this this is seph you're just trying to
get a word out but what
if what if there was somebody your town
they were so kind of like illiterate
that if they couldn't get a word you
[__] hit him
with a little popper
yeah
extra
extracurricular wide away anyways but
he's so specific it's like a I think
about it with when we were kids we would
go on a what was it what was it called
was it called sound click SoundCloud no
no the the Beats oh sound click I think
I don't know what was it so there was a
there was a website called
soundclick.com to get instr it would
have Beats and it would be like
producers would make these beats and
they would lease them to you but they
would title the Beats like and this I I
I dreamed of the day this would happen
for me Drake Type Beat yes yes yes
Eminem type beat and it was like that
spoke so that goes back to the sound we
were talking about earlier in this pod
is like great artists build sounds not
just great songs as well they great
sounds behind them so like the greatest
dream is be like oh that's a John party
sounding song that's a Kid Rock sounding
song that's a jelly roll sounding song
It's a like that is the greatest
compliment because there's a lot of
artists in music on pop and country
that's like there's four artists that
could cut the same song because their
sound is just that sound you know what I
mean it's just a big it's a big like
yeah it's just kind of like down
the-middle
sound yeah people are going to like it
but it's not polarizing which you know
there's an artist you you know what I'm
talking about and then you have the
other artist it's like oh that sounds
like J Cole should be rapping on that
yeah that sounds like jelly roll would
be singing a song like that like that's
what you go for as an art and any Young
artist watching this that's what I
challenge you to do I challenge you to
write a thousand songs and I challenge
you to make production around it in a
way that it's your thing yeah so what
he's saying is you're going to need to
go to
prison do a stin you either go to
college yeah you're going to want to go
to college just for long enough to drop
out of it uh or prison yeah cuz
otherwise nobody will buy your music at
least if you're not a college if you're
not a Dropout you know you got to have a
story with yeah you can't be singing
about pills and dogs and have a degree
in business like pick your life pick
your life yeah and also dude Shout Out
The Producers like Joey specifically
Joey Moy uh just one producer of the
year I mean he's been he's the goat he's
been crushing let me see a picture of
him can we bring a picture of him up
please Alex so Joey's all our producer
me Morgan Hardy he he's a I've met him
before yeah you've met Joey so he's
like Joey my no dude took that picture
but um he's the goat goat though he has
done such a good job of for years even
since Nickelback he's been able to build
several different brands within the same
genre and make each of them unique like
how different me Morgan and Hardy are
within the same exact format is he also
Florida Georgia Line
Georg big stuff yeah it's like awesome
Joey Joey built all of this and I mean
I'll give Hardy credit too on he's very
Hands-On on his sound and um and what he
wants to sound like they're very what's
the word collaborative uh Hardy and Joey
are but yeah yeah Kudos Tim that's
amazing you know to have to be able to
have that those AB you know that ability
to to be able to organize not only like
put something together but then find
different places for things that are
really great that can be close to each
other and stuff it's yeah it's insane is
it true that on the Nickelback record
that what the hell is on Joey's head
that's Joey about Joey that's Joey so
yeah I think he had like a fake Stanley
Cup on his head in this photo and they
were like stoned and um I think Joey's
on the cover of High Times or something
like that with Chad at one point but uh
yeah that the yeah look at this
Photograph every time and what the hell
is on Joey's head oh that was it Joey MO
W so but think about this while we're
giving him his flowers
is Joey think about this Joey did
Nickelback and the like created the
sound that made Nickelback the icons
they are yeah then went on to do it with
Florida Georgia Line yeah Hardy Ernest
and then Morgan yeah so it's like his
spectrum of decades worth of just rein
like that's a genius dude like it's
outside of him inventing artist sounds
he's Reinventing himself like he's like
there's something different happening
with that dude man you I mean yeah to be
able to change yeah I I can't it's hard
enough for somebody to do something well
once yeah for sure to to produce a song
like Animals you know or something in
your mouth by Nickelback and then also
have like seven Summers yeah and how
different they are I think about last
night like
just shout out Charlie hansome too yeah
crazy yeah Charlie
H he's so [__] good I got to have I
got I got to have a talk with Charlie
yeah Charlie's a cool cat yeah what are
you going to tell him man let's get it
out just how much I love him okay D how
much I love him I thought it was going
to be about his use or something I love
too I was like yo is this where we're
going I was like when when I met Charlie
it was
200 18 we were at the Universal Studios
uh the recording studios not the Disney
World and he's a songwriter just so
people know Charlie hansome producer
srer bring a picture of him up and truly
one of the greatest yeah truly he
started out
uh like a hip-hop producer but like he's
one of the greatest musicians like he
plays all instruments he kind of was the
first producer to do that acoustic trap
stuff like the early on post Malone
stuff glex stuff like that that's his
gut string guitar and
he he does all these crazy vocal effects
so anyways I met Charlie in 2018 when I
was like kind of rapping
that's that's uh one guy is Charlie hand
the guy on the left yeah that's Charlie
those are handsome Charlies dude for
sure I [__] with that dude with four
cigarettes in his mouth though but that
dude is [__] IC shout out that guy
too yeah that's Charlie but Charley's a
man and so we met doing some rap stuff
and we talked that day uh about he was
like yo I got to come to Nashville he's
like I want to get into country and I
was at that time had a foot in both
doors and I was kind of ready to go the
country route foot in what door raping
in country yeah like that's why I was
out in La just like making rap beats and
doing Hooks and stuff know I was I was
just making the rounds out there and
then coming back here and doing country
and like I already was boys with Morgan
for a couple years at that time and Sam
Hunt and FGL so like Charlie came into
town and we started doing tag team in
all these sessions together and that's
when like if I know me for Morgan came
heartless for Morgan more than my
hometown with them and like it all
started happening and my first number
one ever was a song called I love my
country with Florida George ofine Me and
Charlie did um and we just we kind of
sat there and accidentally manifested
the whole thing is what we talked about
that day was like y I feel like we could
go really and organically blend these
two sounds in Nashville uh and and it's
happened I mean putting it's not like
we're the first to ever put 808s with a
country song because Joey was doing it
with Cruz back when FGL was doing it but
I think I think it's happened I got to
give my boys flowers too Zack Crow did
it with break up Z break up in a small
town he might have been the first to do
it probably so yeah but straight up so
the way it's evolved organically though
to where it's like it doesn't sound like
such a mes it just sounds like one brand
and then it's the voice that's pulling
it home well it's probably getting into
people's systems too after it gets in
their system a little bit they're kind
of used to hearing it without frog in
warm water so speak Char Charlie
Charlie's Charlie's really one of those
special ones man shout out shout outow
too shout out to Ernest by the way erest
Ernest it's funny how Ernest always
finds himself you know and he's so
humble about he's like yo this guy and
this guy and this guy was like you
always be in the room too [__] I
know you I've been with you you're
[__] He's something special I sneak
into a lot room yeah Ernest is er don't
sneak I always love Ernest that he's uh
always makes me laugh he's one of the
funniest guys to be around he's [__]
hilarious he's my favorite face time if
I look down at my phone and it's a
FaceTime and it's Earnest I'm like I
don't every time you're like I don't
know what this is but it's going to be
[__] awesome you what I'm
saying it could be a hit song idea he
could be up [__] partying on his bus
at 4 morning he could just have a bit
call with a joke like yo check this out
just [__] like like just like I know
if Co wetzel's on with him on the same
FaceTime then I'm going to need to call
my
SP yeah I'm going to merge calls with my
sponsor the idea of Co wetel makes my
liver and nose hurt hearing his name I
just got PTSD we got to get Co on here
man [__] D he's people everybody
loves him so much I'd probably do an
afternoon one with him he's not awake
there's no unless he if he's awake he's
hunting right now yeah he's he has been
him I just seen a picture of Gary Dale
posted that him and his dad have been
out killing [__] he's an AF yeah he can
hunt I mean I love Co man he's such a
good dude he's one of he's uh his whole
crew is cool he's also man shout out Dre
Dre is the dude Dre Roa yeah [__] the
dude man but I tell you something else
about Co that I think gets overlooked
because he's he's so fun and the party
and just who he is is just also man he's
incredible dude like if you see him with
just a guitar I mean I've seen him
blowed out of his mind pick up a guitar
and just kill it's like so second nature
to what he does he's so ingrained in the
music side of it you know like we were
in a writing room one day and he was
trying to he was like no here here he's
like just just hand it to me Brantley
Gilbert's like that too and brandley
will throw that guitar on and just man I
mean I always you're a great guitar
player in a room you know what I mean
it's like you notice the ones that are
like different you're like and I think
maybe Co CAU off guard cuz I didn't
expect it cuz we partied all night the
night before like all night till like 9
in the morning or something it was like
[__] got dark it was [__] deep and
I was just like we got to the studio
like 4 the next afternoon we're both
like shaking you know what I mean we're
both in really bad shape you've been
there and it's like and I'm watching
this dude just pour a song out of him
I'm like this is crazy y I brought no
value I had to leave I was like yo I'm
out I feel so bad I'm trying to have sex
on cocaine that's me bu I'm going to
bring nothing to the table yeah let me
uh yeah I can't even bring the
table getting this up the stairs I've
already sold the table you were talking
about somebody um like Joey getting to
live there few people get to do it once
and we were talking about Tyler hubber
for a second yeah Tyler I'll tell you a
great story about Tyler so I went to I
this actually isn't a great story but it
is a story and um I just realized it
wasn't that great okay but we went to
see uh we saw Hardy and Morgan in Ernest
at um fway park right and it was
beautiful like beautiful day great set
wa place to see a show cuz you're inside
fway Park where you've seen baseball but
youve never seen a show in there and
like Hardy's up there with the American
flag and like ernest's kid runs out on
the stage with him oh ryen twinkle
twinkle yeah second he heard a song
though he's like I'm out of here he
really came got me he's like dude this
guy's [__] bunk right it's his
dad I was like dude that's your father
we have to little respect I need a
cigarette he'll be there yeah I think he
really liked the music he just wanted
some nicotine yeah um but anyway
afterwards I'm leaving and I'm like [__]
I stayed a little too late to be able to
beat like like we had to just walk back
to my hotel so and it was a w it was
probably a half a mile so I'm like so I
get out there and I'm kind of start to
argue with this cab driver a little bit
he does we don't we nether one of us
speak the other guy's language right so
we're trying to figure out how far I
need to go uh and Tyler pulls right up
dude with his family oh incredible like
you want to get in yes dude and I was
like thank you man Cruz bro Cruz Cruz I
think I think he's going to be one of
the few that got to live his dream twice
wow it looks like it with the songs he's
putting out he's a sweet guy yeah the
hits he's getting on country radio good
to me yeah he been great and uh I think
I told him that one night I was like man
very few men in life get to live their
dream once and I think you're fixing to
get to do it twice wow technically three
times cuz then you and BK will get back
together later and go do huge blowout
reunion thing and it'll be [__] big
again you I'm saying yeah what'll happen
with them yeah can that happen that
Florida Georgine can get back together
you think I don't you know he knows them
better than me I just met BK the other
day who I'm who I think waset chess pie
they have both always been so they've
both always been so good to me like I
said bro when I was when I was still
snow they had me come that was your
rapper name yeah I was just like and
nickname it was just that era I marked
that era like 200 14 201 2011 through
2014 was the snow days and and those
were like Brian and Tyler had I had no
business being in a room writing songs
with them and and they and big loud and
them took a way early chance on me years
before I needed it well that's another
another nod to like people changing
genres and thinking of something
different because who would think I'm
going to get a white rapper yeah you
know or who would think you know a lot
of guys probably weren't thinking hey
I'm going to get this rapper in here to
try with me you know right yeah it's
cool I mean and then you
know having having the rapper mentality
and then having also signed a country
writing publishing deal kind of forced
my
hand to just start doing a weird hybrid
where I was like I was really rapping
like I would be like doing 16 Bar verses
like a rap would but I was adding
Melodies and doing it over acoustic and
stuff like that and then you know that
was just like I said putting the frog in
war water I was the frog in warm water
as far as finally fully committing the
brand and craft to like country song
writing and like I think I Shi away from
it for so long CU I thought you had to
be redneck to be country and I'm not the
most redneck guy I've done redneck [__]
with my friends I got redneck friends
for sure but I'm country and I'm and it
took me a while to even realize that cuz
you know I didn't grow up on a farm we
moved to 13 Acres my senior year which
was not because of poverty you know it's
like I had a pretty decent um so I like
Shi away from the country thing I don't
want to be fake but I see but some of my
favorite songs ever written ain't got
nothing to do with big trucks and muds
like love or heartbreak and pain and
it's like oh being a country artist can
just be telling your story and the music
is my favorite music anyway so like once
I wrap my head around that wasn't a
shame to be country and realize I am
country then I was like yeah let's let's
go I'm not redneck dude I'll never
forget the first time my mama played uh
looking for trouble and I found a son
right down a barrel of a long man gun
ain't living long like this ain't living
long like this on my baby and I was like
yo this [__] country huh who's saying
that way Jen that sounds like you that's
what's crazy doesn't it I mean it sounds
like that's the sh that's the sh that's
what inspired me though right that was
the stuff that I was like yo this is
awesome you know it's like that was to
me um Willie Nelson's Blue Eyes Crying
in the Rain these like Classic record
Angel Flying Too Close to the ground
dude man and Lucas doing it at the
birthday party was insane too oh that's
one of my favorite songs Just he his the
whole catalog of Willie was Willie
inspired me to understand that the
person out the the pain like I used to
think because I was like a bubbly big
dude that I couldn't sing sad songs but
all I wrote was sad songs you know what
I mean and then you look at guys like
Willie you know the braids the guitar
the headband and then he goes he's like
famous Stoner like who Willie is outside
of the music yeah and then he would get
on stage and sing the saddest song ever
you know what I mean it was like that
inspired me so so much but and just high
enough to come back around round I think
they'll get back together Florida
Georgia Line I think their impact was
too big I don't know if it's in the next
5 years or 10 but it's just like I'm
still holding on to hope I just listened
to Andre 3000's flute album yeah I was
just high enough to really dig it to be
honest but I was thinking to myself
there's no way even if we don't see an
outcast album ever again that there's
not going to be a day where something's
going to come along that we're going to
see outcast on the stage again I hope so
thing out unless you plan the V yeah you
know what I mean I just don't think I
think their their cultural impact was
too big oh dirt is a song I'll play a
lot of times man yeah for sure dirt
confession anything goes yeah hey I'll
show Chris Tomkins demo of anything goes
it's just him and a keyboard I'll show
you I'll show all y'all one day I'm
trying to think of uh what else is
something I was going to think about
asking you boys let me try let me show
this new hat I got you like this hat I
got yeah tell me
Lane it's a
uh this Lane this Lane
Frost he is a um his daddy was a uh will
you bring him up do you mind if you get
a chance Alex I gotta make a phone call
really quick No Sweat I'll talk to jelly
I love that Ernest is so Earnest he's
like I gotta make a phone call like he's
like I'm just high enough to remember I
was supposed to call my doctor 12 he's
like [__] he's like dude I'm doing
obviously I don't need to be in here uh
Lane Frost right there celebrating a
bull riding Legend one of the best bull
riders of all time um yeah can we get on
his Wikipedia at least it might help us
some yeah oh he died in 1989 yeah why he
died
young his parents lived in La Point
Utah his father was on the rodeo
circuit um yo hold on hold on this is
crazy he sustained severe injuries at
the 1989 Cheyenne Frontier Days Rodeo I
played that before it's a huge deal dude
me and coow wetel played that really
dude I'm headlining sh frontier days
this year Theo if you're off that day
you should come out and see it it is the
wildest [__] [__] you it's so
legendary it's it is like seeing that
just gave me goosebumps you know think
about George Straits I can still make
Cheyenne uh think about uh think about G
Brook's beaches
a drew a bull in Wyoming no man could
ride I'm getting Goosebumps bro this is
crazy all this was about this guy then
look at that big Goosebumps bro wow
that's true huh it must have been about
him look oh damn oh those are real right
there some [__] buzzards you got
going baby damn that's the power of
music and stuff you hatching buzzards
right there go back to uh to Lane Frost
real quick and go down a little bit more
on him early life on January 5th Frost
married Kelly Kyle a barrel racer and
then how did he pass
away on July 30th at Cheyenne Frontier
Days in Chey Wyoming after completing a
successful 85po ride on a Brahma bull
named taking care of business uh Frost
dismounted and landed in the mud the
bull then turned and pressed his right
horn on Frost's back and pushed him
against the muddy floor uh he was rushed
to he fell to the ground causing his
heart and lungs to be punctured by his
ribs oh he died on the way to the
hospital was 25 years old man you got to
come with me this year if I do it that's
crazy
dude um I will that's amazing man I
appreciate you saying that I'll have to
this sounds really really cool oh
there's movie 8
Seconds where Luke Perry uh rip played
the roll of frost and he has a son
though Lane Frost I think is maybe is
this maybe or this maybe this uh hat
line might just be named after him yeah
Frost
parents say oh they play tribute to him
with the dance video that g Brooks put
out this is crazy wow country music star
Zack Bryan's middle name is Lane after
Frost wow what are the odds bro what are
the odd somebody
gave me this hat the other day I see it
across the room I go put it on and we're
back down to Zack Frost I want one now
and it's 2022 song open the gate as a
tribute to his Nam sake wow man that's
awesome gosh dude there's something
about storytelling man there's something
about that people get you know you want
people to relate to things and feel
something yeah you know have you CU what
is music look like do you think moving
forward for you you know do you think
like more about it I mean do you think
like
about staying more in a certain Lane you
all good Earnest I'm great okay cool no
worries we'll just go a little bit
longer Man U do you think about staying
in a different lane or doing it do you
have any thoughts like or is there new
stuff you working on or what's yeah man
I'm actually I'm actually proud to say
this I've got more Demos in my phone
right now than I've ever had like I've
wrote more this year than I've wrote in
a year in a long time I just wrote on
the tour this year I've been gone all
year I've only slept in my bed 36 days I
don't think we I don't know we got that
on the early part of this but I've been
gone like that much this year so it's
like I've just been writing wherever I
can whenever I can and it's really
ignited a flame in me again about the
writer side I've been writing a lot of
songs just by myself again just with
folks or just oh by yourself by with
folks too but I've been doing a lot of
just like me falling back you've been so
busy too you bet I bet you ain't slep in
your bed 90 days this year no it it has
been crazy but your touring so unor
you're on tour this week you got show
two days but see we tour different
you're doing like the pop
I'm G yeah rock and roll I'm gone for
four months and not home at all and we
go out every weekend you know we're back
Monday I hat that though let's talk
about that you do the stuff too I'm kind
of sporadic yeah I'll do like four days
in a week and then I'll take off a week
or I'll do two weeks four four days five
days and then take off for two weeks see
what they're doing that I don't like is
that's cool that's actually the way to
do it probably the way they do it and I
don't like this respectfully everybody
does their own way but it's not my way
they do probably no [__] arnest you're
doing 47 weekends this year if I had to
guess out of 52 weeks Jesus that's a lot
yeah no 45 at least I'd say we
started um we started the first week of
March and
then pretty much every weekend until
this with the exception of when Morgan
had to cancel a few shows I got a couple
extra weekends off and like we got
picked up some gigs during that though
but yeah we filled that up I played a
lot of shows so probably 38 weekends
it's like for me I would never get in
the Rhythm Theo it's like when I'm gone
that much by the time I came home Sunday
and slept Monday I'd get rid of The
Hangover Monday I'd be like all right
I'm feeling better Tuesday I'd start
rotating in the world but Wednesday
night at midnight the bus left again
yeah you know what I mean so it's like I
prefer to rock and roll style tour where
like I just went out and did 11 weeks
and did five shows a week and did 55
shows in 11
weeks I never tried another option I've
never tried that I don't know if I could
hand I personally I don't know I think I
just get we just get two burnt out
probably how many buses you got now four
no we did uh I guess eight or eight or
nine maybe 10 on your tour buses yeah
you got you got your own Bunny's got her
own yeah and then we did seven so it was
nine Jesus Christ you have one bus I
don't know I think we did 10 tractor
trailers too yeah bro big tour man I
mean you got think we did Arenas it was
a big de your production's insane yeah
that's true yeah we did and I want I
wanted to make sure that like I want I'm
very a stickler about doing it right
like if I have to take a haircut and
lose a little money but I know that the
show is going to look that much better
like I bought content for my show nobody
buys content for their shows everybody
uses stock content because it cost a
million dollars you know what I mean and
I was like I'm buying content though
like I want to create my own it's insane
yeah I want I want I know it's a one-of
aind show because they're so hard to do
one-of a kind shows right nothing news
Under the Sun everybody's done it twice
you know what I'm saying it's like we
all got the same video walls to some
degree we only got so much room to play
with you know what I mean and I was like
at least if I create content it took
nine months to build the content for the
tour yeah we're building an animation
right now to play we just got some
screens and some of these venues I may
go back though to just not doing like we
just started doing some Arenas this week
like some smaller kind of a I mean the
word Arenas is kind of loosely used but
like a lot of them are like uh college
basketball places like we call them
hockey arenas yeah are you doing Arizona
State we might I don't know we did uh
Pikeville that was a tough that was
actually a tough room some of the audio
in the rooms is not we we're bringing
our own our speakers and stuff but it's
some of it's not built for what's
Verizon is that the Verizon Center
whatever it is right there in Pik field
it's that little arena in the middle of
downtown Pik I mean and Pikeville is
beautiful it's beautiful I mean it's
like nestled in the mountains it's sexy
unreal it's like this perfect little
place did you drive up there we busted
in yeah we I drove up there cuz the
drive when we played Pikeville that day
I was like I had to dude it was [__]
you drive through that little because
pikeville's up there in like the corner
of Kentucky and
um West Virginia right it's like right
there in that little like mountainous
area right there beautiful it's [__]
aw for a nice hike before but that audio
was that I felt like sometime I just
kind of felt like that venue the audio
was kind of tough at it you ever have
some of those where some of them you're
just like man this just yes and you feel
disappointed cuz you're like it it does
it's not helping me as much you know but
um here here's the deal though I knew
that you were going to have to start
picking up Arenas when I was seeing the
two or three theater shows in a day pop
and you're in a weird spot man where
it's like how do you feel about this
because the problem you're going to run
into if you don't start playing big
Arenas is your people everybody who
wants to come ain't going to be able to
come there's still people not getting a
ticket to see you and you're playing
8,000 cap Arenas there's still people in
that market like damn wish I could have
went to go see Theo Friday without a
ticket you know yeah I don't know I
think I I think part of it is I'll just
keep doing the tour and I'll just come
back instead of trying to do it that's
one nice thing it's like okay we realize
this area we could more people want to
come see it then we'll come back it
again I'd rather do the same like not
the same material but you know let it
evolve over time but do that for five
years and by the end of it it's a whole
new show or you know might be a a new
show and a half by then yeah but it's
like yeah I don't think feeling like I
need to hurry and then get an hour out
and then it's
like you know we'll come back I tell
people all the time if if tickets are
too expens if it's if it's aftermarket
we'll come back might be a year and a
half you know you might not be alive you
might not even be alive you might die
before I get back here but I'll that's
your issue I'll be back how do you um
some that's on them if you don't mind
talking about it where are you at with
your hour um I'm good yeah we're doing
like I'm doing like an hour and 20
minutes on stage right now you feel like
you got a new hour yeah when are you
thinking about filming I don't know if I
will I think I'm just gonna tour for a
while and not hurry myself into that
next space you know me and David Spade
wrote like a movie we might want to try
to get made so we talked about maybe
getting you to would get you as a
anything you need yo I'll do something
too
man in God we're package deal now we
just hired you you're hired yeah um
freaking Fred over here but yeah I was I
was going to present at the CMAs
actually they asked but I had a show
that night in
uh South car Greenville South Carolina
and it was I just got back from
Greenville it's beautiful where did you
go where were you uh on col no okay we
just did the Blind Horse saloons Hy that
place is awesome love that place did you
play Coyote Joe's the night before Char
no we didn't do the two that way from
rocking greenville's beautiful dud
there's so many cool plac Arena down
there on this tour was yo we did our
tour party in Greenville oh I got a
story this is a story I don't know if
it's a good one but it's a
story I love I love the honestly but we
played Greenville and we had the night
off before so what they did was they let
us load in the arena the day before MH
and then we rented this place God
they're going to be so mad I can't
remember their name but it was the
coolest thing ever it was like a it was
an adult playground kind of like they
served booze and they had pizza and they
had a yeah they had a putt putt golf
Center in it you could throw axes they
had like beer pong games they had
pingpong like it was like it was like
one of those like adults yeah but it was
like adult like we were all in there we
rented the whole place and get out drunk
and most of the crew did Whip itss and
blow and it was just crazy I mean it got
really crazy dude it was it was and it
was all 75 people from the tour because
it was like a 75 person crew all the
drivers came because we parked the day
before so the truck drivers and the bus
drivers got to get drunk it was like
watching the bus drivers get drunk
nothing tickled me more you know what
I'm saying because they live a real kind
of like regimented sober you know what I
mean it's like the one night where it's
like y'all don't have to drive for 40
hours like just the buses were already
parked at the venue the venue been
loaded in I hired IVs for everybody the
next day so I had like a 10p person
nursing staff backstage so when
everybody got to The Venue like truck
drivers are getting IVs it was the night
we gave away the bonuses for the tour
what a night dude it was special no that
social no no no this place is way cooler
that place sucks when you find this
place dude you're going to be blown away
that's like a got like a stinks yeah
it's like a mini it's got like Mini Putt
Putt golf um they got ax throwing inside
of there oh they got damn baby burp in
there they had karaoke we were getting
drunk doing karaoke We Are karaoke
struggle songs it was awesome oh that's
so good it was really cool man it was
awesome what uh what else did we have in
the news what was in the news in there
how did uh did y'all think Morgan was
upset about not getting that award you
think he
cared H I mean I don't know they didn't
even let him go there last year right
I'm not sure I don't I don't know if he
was there or not last year I think he
performed I think I remember performing
I think I remember performing I think he
did you proove look but it was really
cool that boy's pockets are fine yeah
he's fine I he's he's got some of the
best fans he's the he's the most um him
getting 11 Billboard Music Awards were
deserved I mean he's the most cuz that
one is not up to anybody except it's uh
is that just stats I think billboard is
stats it's your stats but him truth it's
the yeah him Taylor and Zach are
the juggernauts of streaming like it
doesn't even it doesn't even get
close Morgan Zack and Luke comes are the
three biggest streamed artists in
country music Zack and Morgan and Luke
Luke to some degree in the world of all
artists but Morgan and Taylor are by far
the two juggernauts in the music I mean
it don't it don't get no bigger than
Morgan Wallen on Earth on earth like
he's bigger than Bad Bunny he sold more
records than Bad Bunny mean it's like
all that [__] you think was doing great
Morgan just came in and was like hold my
beer so it's like he's he's so you know
what I mean it's he's in such a
Stratosphere of his own I tell people
this the way I tell them you have Luke
streaming wise Morgan Zack and Luke in
that order of the three biggest
streamers in country music and on
Spotify alone the gap between them and
the next biggest streamed artist in
country music which would probably be
bayy Kane or maybe me weirdly
enough the gap between us three and them
and us three and those three is probably
a billion streams this year crazy on
Spotify alone it's crazy does that make
sense like that's how far four five and
six a billion lower than one two and
three it's crazy it's crazy it's like
it's like well if like imagine if I do
end up being the fourth most streamed
artist in country music somebody said
how far away from the third where you I
go 1.3 billion you know I'm saying light
on Spotify alone you know what I'm
saying it's like we're never going to
get there you know what I'm saying it's
to some degree these award shows have to
be a little different cuz there'd be no
sense of nobody else showing up you know
what I'm saying it's like if we were
like really grading it on that it's like
just give them all the [__] Mor
Taylor you know what I'm saying a great
point you have to make it yeah that's a
good point the the show itself has to
make things kind of exciting and there's
other there's other award shows there's
like the Billboards that it's based on
the stat so there's no like yeah rig
them roll was there an Afterparty or
anything you guys get to go to I had to
go that boy had an after party we parted
me and Lany had our own party shout out
Lany
Wilson l Wilson dude and I don't know if
anybody's worked harder this she we saw
her I got to take my niece to her first
concert right and it was uh Laney we
took her to her and Lany and Hardy in
Baton Rouge and it was cool man you know
she's great and it was just so much fun
she got to meet her and it was just but
man she was you could tell that she was
getting burnt out she' worked no hard
she slept in her bed last year 17 days
yeah 17 days of all of 2022 is how many
days she slept in her bed it's in like
wow this is what I say I'm willing to do
the stuff nobody else in this town's
willing to do as far as like work like
media go spend three weeks in New York
or what like I go do that that's just
what I do I'm into it she's willing to
do the stuff I won't do like Laney I've
never seen nobody work genuinely harder
than her her schedule gives me anxiety m
you know what I mean and my schedule
would give the average human anxiety and
her schedule gives me anxiety like she
has she is utterly Fearless no dude I
think I think she stood on stage 160
something times this year yeah 170 times
this year that's just for it's 45 minute
being the smallest set 90 being the
biggest all year it's insane you know
what I me yeah yeah that's wild man cuz
all the things radio all the streaming
things oh the Yellow Stone obligation
she she's she is make a gumbo babysit
your cat she'll have everything on her
schedule yeah well we talked about this
the other day like I think she's
obviously and you two are going to be
able to say no a lot more yeah than you
were able to in the last year or two and
saying yes is like you got to for for a
lot of those things and obviously it's
like paid off and people are recognizing
it the work and I I would I would be
remiss not to say that you know dude I
when I called lip thank you I called
Laney for save me I said Lany I'm going
to be honest man I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
I've said this a thousand times but I'm
hitching my trailer to your train here
I've took this song as far as it can go
wow this song was a double Platinum song
that's kind of true in in an interesting
way huh because that song I'd heard it
I'd listen to it a bunch and it still
had its place in my heart in moments
where I was by myself and I like to
listen to it but it kind of that was you
got to hear a different perspective a
different voice a woman's perspective I
was like and and as hot as she is at
country radio I was like this is all you
even when we got to the last chorus when
she did all the ad libs and extra stuff
she's like you want to come in here and
sing back and forth I was like not at
all as far as I'm concerned this is now
your song you know what I'm saying this
I was a double platinum record when I
gave it to her I was like yo this I've
done all I can do with this song but I
think this song could still help so many
people if you would just be a part of it
and she was like yeah I'm totally in and
there's no way that this was my a number
one in 16 weeks by myself or 20 weeks or
whatever it ended up being you know what
I mean so she she definitely
she definitely came in and put her sauce
on it yeah she really I mean we got to
have her come in and she's from
Louisiana she's from bastri I think will
you look that up please for me sounds
right you're bum [__] [__] Bas Robins
Louisiana like yeah she's from dipping
dot
Louis Basin sorry Basin Basin Carol
Baskin yeah huh [__] [__] killed her
hus remember
that remember when
no reason America somebody wrote online
yeah Carol Baskin killed her husband and
everybody for two years like that [__]
K Joe Dirt still wants her dead from
prison and now she's doing not Joe Dirt
Joe Exotic same difference dude
literally the same
guy same guy Joe Joe
Exotic Joe Exotic that dude's always
dming me all the time man Joe Exotic is
in your D whoever in his Instagram
account is [__] ridiculous I used to
know I used to know the person that ran
I used to know the person that ran it
yeah really [__] ridiculous there's
no way he's running it was it a male it
was a female it was okay felt female
energy is yeah he did
too oh yeah he was a Bo he he's probably
the most gangster gay dude that ever
lived though gangster spelled g a y n
g he's a gangster yeah dude that's
[__] crazy oh if so you dude to be
real scared if you're scared somebody's
going to shoot you and then make love to
you and you're not into it it's going to
really spook you it gets interesting out
yeah what other cool things have you
turned down this year besides presenting
at the
CMAs yeah and Joe Exotic Jo
ex sorry to repeat your joke man I just
want I repeated it too I wanted to make
sure it got hurt um I don't know that
was probably about the ne maybe one of
the neatest things that came along kind
of where they were like do you want to
do this but i' already we already had a
soldout show and I just felt bad yeah
and I'm glad I did the show the show was
awesome you know there were some moments
where I felt bad about it it would have
been fun you know I know pton Manning
was there you guys were there um so I
all your friends this town loves you
dude I still want you to do the opery
Bro do it one of the nights I'm doing it
let's do the opery together let's all
three do the opery we got all three to
the oper one we we'll support I'll call
Jordan about that right now when I leave
well you know you know they want you
there you can't make mind maybe if my I
think I would my mom would probably like
to go so maybe if she's going to be yeah
I would have her maybe come in for that
we should do like the grand old opera
and do a night of it for real I'm not if
y'all are cool I'll call Jordan about it
right now some clean material over there
you just got to keep it pretty clean
yeah yeah but I mean you just can't cuss
they don't mind if it's risky they just
mind RIS they mind about the cuss words
cuz it's on the radio it's still the
actual I as I finally asked him I was
like yo what's what's the real story
here about the cussing he was like it's
on the radio yeah he's like the FCC he's
like it's live radio show steal to this
day so what's the actual deal here I was
like well that's no all those all those
the people that are the Opry fans would
love a little risque I mean dude think
about it heha we were talking about
it has a history of you know iffy comedy
yeah for sure yeah heaw man did you know
so I was I went to see the Arizona
Diamondbacks play a game one time and
they had um the manager his dad larusa I
think his name is
no way Tony larusa no it's not him okay
it's a Diamondbacks
manager he uh yeah Tor lavulo his father
produced
hehw really this dude comes up to me
goes hey man we're said I live that gave
you the Diamond Back Jersey yeah he gave
me a cool one it says Rat King on the
back um but anyway just kind of an
interesting piece that his father Sam
lavulo there you go was a producer for
hehw that was a great show they still
Hew stage there I was um I played the
opy last night I did the oery last night
yeah uh me Chris Janson Riley green and
Nelly did the for the big friends giving
for the big 98 here wow perfect y dude
you you you work hard bro you do so much
stuff jelly man I'm just so blessed to
be here though Theo man you like I feel
you there it's so different when I get
to hang out with you in Earnest because
y'all would like remember when it wasn't
like this for me and it's like this is
all I wanted it to be though so like now
that I'm in it like I just feel like I
don't even want to disrespect God like
that kind of like I prayed for this for
so many years and so many dude I I um
I'm filming a special for a television
show uh CBS Sunday Morning what they
call it it's big big deal and I'm they
took me back to my old jail yesterday no
wow the jail that I found out I had my
daughter in like the jail I was in when
she was incarcerated they took me back
to my old cell what was that like for
you one I walked in there certain I
wasn't going to be emotional cuz I
walked in so happy and in such a good
mood and I and dude I walked in the unit
still happy we're chatting I'm telling
them Stories We Walk upstairs and as
soon as I walked in that cell I cried
like a Baby Dude I mean like I lost it
completely because it was like every
memory I'm getting choked up now it's
like every memory from that jail cell
like every song I I spent like a year
and a half in that cell dog like the
hearing I had a daughter every song I
wrote everything I went through and
you're just sitting there like man this
is unreal dude thank you brother sad it
makes me sad I mean it makes doesn't
make me sad but it makes me yeah it's
powerful to think of somebody being
caged up and then being as free as you
are no it's unreal and I walk out of
there I'm getting choked up too and I'm
like I leave there and go back to my old
halfway house at the men of valor I go
see them boys and it's like such a like
humbling thing for me and then I go do a
show with Nelly and Riley green and I'm
on [__] the biggest podcast on Earth
the next day like it's you and Rogan
dude you know it you know what I'm
saying it's like you know I'm just like
man this is just such a just I'm so like
blessed dog and that's why I do all the
give back stuff it's like how could God
bless me so much and me not want to
bless somebody you know what I mean yeah
and I know you have a toy drive that's
going on right now that people can hit
yeah any Walmart Middle Tennessee okay
they got a box right there that you
could just drop off toys at the Box uh
I'm going to put a couple hundred grand
up myself we're going to do over 100,000
toys it'll be the biggest one in
Nashville I mean just look who got
behind us dude it's crazy the Predators
cocacola Hasbro uh the Nashville fire
department Walmart has been a partner in
this I mean man that's so my dream is in
the next 5 years for this to be a
national thing that I do with Walmart
and we raise millions and millions of
toys for uh underprivileged kids I love
so what do I go in there and buy toys
and put them in a box yeah yeah just
drop them right in the box man yeah just
drop them right in the box and it's cool
because it's convenient we're all in and
out of Walmart All Season you know what
I mean so it's like all you got to do is
just buy an extra toy and dude going in
Walmart that used to be fun dude I'll
tell you a story you don't mind me
getting yeah you're right huh sometimes
there's nothing else to do on the road
but go to my wanted to do this oh yeah
and she started this five six years ago
at a local bar in White House Tennessee
with her aunt where they would just pick
them up from the bar staff and people
and she'd go give away 20 30 toys she
was doing this at 9 years old this was
her thought and I looked back at it and
when I got out of
jail give me a
second I came home like December
of
2009 I didn't have any money for toys
you know in the halfway house the men of
valor did a toy drive for the for the
guys that just came home and I remember
dropping off a
truck of toys I couldn't afford for her
Christmas and um I didn't even get to
meet her at that time I wasn't CT by
Court I wasn't even allowed to see her
wow I just got home
wow so her heart to want to do this toy
driveing and then me to be able to be in
a situation to amplifi is like it's
really cool that is
amazing [__] I said I was going to cry
today I was like I'm not going to be
[__] emotional today I've had
emotional week I got nominated for a
Grammy having a [__] weird couple
weeks damn dude you the only dude I know
who's been nominated for a Graham an a
Grammy to be honest I love you that's so
good that's so good and split split one
of them with you yeah split one of them
with
me oh yeah that's incredible bro but
it's crazy so it's like to see this
thing come to life as like I think
that's why I'm so passionate about
giving back to juvenile and I'm so
passionate about going to jails and
rehabs and singing for people and
investing in rehab facilities and like
like a meeting with our mayor and our
governor about the fitting all epidemic
and a plan and you know what I mean it's
like cuz these are the things that
affected my life you know what I mean
like the [__] that touches you the
closest to home yeah you know what I
mean so yeah we want to build a center
that's one of our goals next year is to
try to find some land to build like a
halfway house like I don't know if it'
be a halfway house or a detox probably a
place where you could also have meetings
at you know where would you do it at I
don't know somewhere close enough like
somewhere here let me tell you this and
I'll say this on your show publicly
whatever I can do like whatever you want
to do like I don't care if we maybe we
do like a string of [__] shows or
something that I'll put together and
just donate the money or what like I'm
into that in a way you'll never
understand thanks like if you like if
nobody else like and this is what I say
off camera too I'll say it to you but
like not even just on some like raise
money [__] like I'll cut a [__] check
yeah same like I [__] I hate people
that go step just raise money you know
what I mean like if you're not that's
why I tell everybody don't worry I'm
putting money into this toy drive like
I'm going to write a big check because
I'm not just going to be a face of one
my face can help bring more attention to
us that's the only reason I even talk
about this stuff we did philanthropy for
years and never spoke about it but I
realized that our platform's so big that
we can help bring attention and money to
the cuse but it's still important to me
my daddy raised me man shut the [__] up
and cut a check you know what I mean
that's just something I learned from a
kid you know yeah no it's I appreciate
that man and we're going to do the same
thing we want to make yeah we just want
to do something a place I can go to
meetings you know where other guys can
go that'd be neat where people maybe we
could do a songwriter night where
songwriters come by and play play some
songs with the guys or we do something
but yeah it's a big goal of mine man
it's just so important I just so many
friends of mine and myself so many
people in my own family just so many
people struggling that's why I think I
can feel when you talk about that kind
of stuff you know I know what it's like
to not be caged up like by walls but to
be caged up by even just somebody's own
their own life caged up by their own
feelings you know man when you're just
locked inside of yourself you know can't
get outside of your own head that's the
worst prison I've been to a lot of jails
and the worst one on earth is between
the ears man yeah you
know
um let's let's check a news thing or two
and then we'll get you guys out here
we've that's the funny thing about
podcast you just never know where it's
going to get you don't really know
what's going to happen you know it's I
love that's why I love them yeah because
it is just like yeah we have microphones
on but this is just conversation we'd be
having at Coffee we might not even get
this deep over coffee that's what I like
about at the mo have enough time we'd be
rushing to our next thing right that's
what I think is the beauty of being
friends now with homies like having
homies like Theo and you that like we
have crazy years where Theo's rocketed
into Arenas I did my first Arena tour
you came off a stadium tour into your
first big theater tour two nights at the
ryen you know what I mean like all these
things you're still writing it's like we
don't get to talk the way we want to so
we get to sit down for homies for two
hours with a microphone in front of us
and it's almost like catching up yeah
Tru you know what I'm saying it's really
cool it's like it's deeper than just
like what's going on in your life it's
like the [__] we'd do on the phone if we
had time to Y you know what I mean yeah
I realized that one time I left out of
Joe Rogan's podcast and and he's so B
he's a super busy guy you know and he
just is just his life he's Build A busy
life and he has a busy life he's not too
busy for you he just has a busy life and
he has a lot of friends and I was like
man I wish I'd have spent more of that
time when I was talking with him like
cuz sometimes you think oh I'm on a
podcast but then sometimes you're just
like catching up with the buddy you know
right I was like I need to make sure
that I spend that time like catching up
with a buddy because sometimes your life
is busy and that's all the time you get
especially you also get older you have
both you guys have children it's like
there's [__] going on you know it's like
so yeah the time you get with people
this is important you know and even
though it is on a podcast it's like it's
still that's the time oh for sure that
you have I was I had cam Haynes flew
down here to the show last night oh did
he really yeah cam haes we were talking
about you last night he's cam Haynes the
not the Cameron Haynes uh hammeron keep
hammering oh Cameron Haynes yeah yeah
damn uh I love that he was like the
underwear guy
[__] yeah CER keep Hammer yeah yeah
keep hammering oh that's right he said
you guys were going to see each other
yeah for sure he came out here and we we
we spent all night together last night
man at least I'm not surprised when I'm
an idiot anymore he's like the underwear
guy I used to feel bad when I and I got
confused cuz I was like maybe cam has an
underwear deal I didn't know about he's
on fire he wrote a book I was like [__]
maybe he did do an underwear deal if he
could write a
book goddamn pair of underwear make some
drawers listen I don't think there's
anything on Earth cam hands can't do uh
here's a guy that would be working on
one of your uh there's this could be
working at one of your deals Tennessee
man arrested for DUI meth while driving
a lawn mower Santa's Train full of kids
whoa so was the DUI for meth or he get
caught with meth and a DUI I mean see
this is what's wrong with cuz listen if
he was drunk and had meth on him I kind
of understand that's the balance of an
equation feel like You' been pretty
dialed at driving dude yeah for sure
it's like I definitely not falling
asleep behind the wheel we've done two
different kind of meths that's for sure
yeah dude I think first of all this is
what's wrong with the US Postal System I
want I say that this is it that this is
how they deliver acting erratically what
did it say uh Henry me was driving
Santa's train a motorized lawn mower
pulling carts of
children which first of all seems like a
bad idea oh they found meth
first narcotics and a
Ser I wonder what the narcotics are I
hope they took pills probably pills they
took them hope they took the blade off
that thing that's all I'm hoping
officials noted that me was not a town
employee that's what the okay yeah I can
guarantee mayor what to make that
definitely clear tazwell Police
Department responded swiftly to the
incident ensuring the safety of the
attendees in the event 14 police Jesus
it was a parade a parade he went to a
parade a parade bunch of
kids it out
on pocket hey that's one way to do it
dude oh my goodness what else we got
anything else
popping that's that's so Tennessee for a
couple terms with felony after public
sex it was always a dream of mine that
shouldn't be a crime look why does she
look so sad if you just fulfilled a
dream I'm confused me and Bunny would
look the polar opposite right now we'd
be on that [__] chees Che me and
Bunny would be you guys do seem like a
public sex type of
public sex listen bunny is a wild woman
y' man what are you getting money for
Christmas do you know jelly huh you know
what you'll get her for Christmas you I
get my I got something cooking for her
man so we quit doing the gifts okay a
couple years ago because we realized
that it was just getting stupid like as
far as like you know yeah what are you
yeah what are we you know like whatever
so like now we do trips like we'll like
put our money together and be like all
right this is what we would about each
other let's go to so we're going to go
somewhere and just spend some time
together man like she is
still my favorite human to be around
like we've been married almost eight
years I'm sure you feel like that about
Delaney but it's like when I have a free
moment to hang out with somebody that's
the first person I think of I'm like I
wonder what my wife's doing you know
what I'm saying like she's like there's
nobody in life I want to be alone with
more the homie than the homie you know
what I'm saying like I just want to
spend like every minute I can like she's
like my favorite hang she's funny she's
goofy she's a [__] wild [__] you
know what I'm saying she's [__] wild
she's like she's she's she's the perfect
woman man she's like for me so for like
short we'll probably take a trip
somewhere I am going to get her a little
something just because I got it's like a
real personal thing but she's uh we're
gonna probably just go out and do
something like just me and
her what about you and Delaney brother
we're going our first we're going to
Mexico oh damn brother going to Mexico
I've never been to Mexico other than off
the FGL crew is um Delan yeah as far as
gifts go it's like she wants I think new
um new forks and knives and like a dope
espresso machine yeah but that's what we
call that the house gift cuz we'll do
that too we'll be like all right what do
we need you know like we had bought a
fridge last year you know that's how old
and married we are you know it's like we
need a new fridge yeah appliances I'm
getting her countertops and like I think
we're getting 20 15ot tall trees in the
backyard like that there Merry Christmas
it's a Christmas trees yeah she buddy
doesn't want roses she wants a rose bush
you know what I'm saying it's different
you know yeah what are you doing for
Thanksgiving I'm going to go what am I
doing I'm going down to uh Dustin por
does a fundraiser thing every year they
hand out hams down there in Louisiana
called the good fight Foundation yeah um
and so I'm GNA go down there and do that
and then we got a show the day after
Thanksgiving at the lake uh UNL where I
saw my first concert at you like front
really God that's a oh that are you
excited about that one yeah I'm pretty I
am excited I know that other people I
know that a lot of my friends are
excited so I think I'm almost more
excited for them I think in a weird way
like just cuz I know they're excited is
it nerve-wracking having a bunch of
people you know in the audience I think
my fear is that they're going to uh like
yell out and stuff the whole time which
for music is fine but like with comedy
you don't want the you know you want
people kind of just being more silent
and stuff you think they just aren't
going to know how to act is that kind of
where you're at well we had a show I I
shot my first like I shot a a comedy
special in Louisiana one time and people
had never been to a comedy show before
they don't even have a com comedy club
like in New Orleans so people didn't
know what to do people were like there
were people in the crowd I remember this
one lady just yelling defense the whole
time
like yeah a football like a bunch of LSU
F yeah like people had like one of those
that's the most rattling that's got to
be how do you crowd work with that
unreal and I think she even had one of
those fence cut out like man do you know
where you are right now oh I thought my
career was over after I shot that I was
like this is
they one of the dud with that helmet
with like the two beer cans Andover I
was like what the [__] are we doing [__]
the
Packers what so that was kind of wild um
what about thankful man what are some
things baby you guys are thankful for
and you know sometimes I make gratitude
lists like in the morning you know yeah
so I'm trying to think of something this
that I'm thankful for you know I'm
thankful that
um I'm thankful that I don't give up on
myself you know I think if that's
something that I had to be thankful for
you know I'm thankful that I don't give
up on myself when uh or I give up on
myself less than I used to right y you
know that's a good one I um each day I'm
more thankful for my son Ryman and
Delaney being the badass she is like as
much as I'm
gone and not able to be there I I'm
thankful that I have a peace of mind
knowing that everything is good and
Ryman is getting the most love and
attention and I get at home and he's
growing and like acquiring such a cool
little sense of humor and personality
and it's like I owe that to Delaney
because she's in there making sure that
every little want and need is taken care
of and she's on her hands and knees
playing trains with them and stuff and
paying all kinds of attention to them so
I'm thankful for that yeah amen and
trains are damn dangerous DN track
always train track [__] playing chicken
with the train he's playing train
Mama yeah and a guy just got arrested
for driving a kids's train smoking me Fu
it's a lot different than when we got a
train where a kid I was wondering why he
didn't call me back yesterday
too his phone died I'm thankful for my
uh I'm thankful for my relationship with
God and my higher power it's really
anchored me this year to be present CU
like having such a successful year it's
really like I've never been more present
in where I am you know what I mean like
even in this conversation like I'm more
relaxed and laid back now and just more
like just being more present like I
thought I lost my phone yesterday and I
realize I think I lose my phone every
day now because I'll just set it down
and wherever I'm at in that moment is
just where I am and then I'll go look
for the phone at the end of the day you
know what I mean it's kind of where I've
been at of my life and I'm just really
thankful for that I'm thankful for my
family my wife of course my children but
I'm thankful for my presence because
like I've been present around them but
not present man you know what I mean
I've to that point I'm so bad about
being present
I'm I live in the future and in the past
in my head so much and Delaney is so
good about being in the presence it's
like I notice how bad I am at it when
I'm seeing when I'm with somebody that's
so good at it yeah that's why I thank my
higher power that's why I thank God
because like I truly like that's my
anchor that's my meditation it's like my
prayer and my ability to just be like
today I'm just going to like I just want
to be wherever I'm at today I just want
to be there yeah you know what I mean
like that's all that really matters is
like right then I'm just thankful that I
haven't achieved it completely yet but
I'm getting [__] so close and it's
awesome dude it's a really cool feeling
how do you keep that going how do you
kind of nurture that relationship with
God kind of uh for just more praying and
just more trying to clear my mind just
more meditation and grounding myself
like when you pray kind of what's it
like like what do you uh well you know I
pray an old traditional Southern Baptist
prayer it's just my praying ways of of
course
um you know I I'll I'll always say the
Serenity Prayer every day just cuz
that's like just so anchoring too but
you know I'm an old school guy that's
just like God I just want to thank you
and I just want to ask you for the
ability to just care and love and I just
want to be I want you to help me be
conscious today of the way I am in this
room you know what I mean and I want to
be a prepared and I want to be a like
man I heard the coolest thing the other
day Theo that said uh if we're searching
if we think our purpose in life is to be
happy how much more narcissistic can we
be our purpose in life is to be useful
and so now it's just more like man I'm a
tool dude yeah you know what I mean like
what can I be a man you know where I'm
getting this from you know what I mean
we'll talk but it's like how can I be of
service like what can I do to actually
be useful to somebody today you know
what I mean like and in every little
scenario like is there something can I
do something cool here can I like that I
I believe firmly that that Spirit the
day of the CM not to get weird and hokey
but I walked out of my front yard in my
boxers and a t-shirt no shoes no socks
boxers now neighbors driving by waving
and I put my bare feet in my front yard
grass and I just looked up at that son
and I just said a little prayer and I
just thought like you know what God I
won being here like I don't care if I
win an award just like help me to open
the show let me do it right let it be a
moment you know what I mean just like
and let me enjoy tonight like regardless
man I set my phone down at the house
when I walked out I didn't have my phone
with me I didn't check my phone till the
next night you know what I mean like I
was present in every situation and
because of that I think when I got on
that stage and scene
5857 something inside of me was like you
thank God you thank your wife you thank
your label and you say something that
[__] matters is what was going
through my mind you know what I mean
because that was that presence of like I
was just so grounded in the present of
that moment I knew then that moment I
wanted to thank Parker McCullum I knew I
wanted to tell Zack Bryan I thought he
was the goat and I knew I wanted to tell
my wife I loved her and I knew that I
wanted to say something that would at
least make a [__] go man he
blessed me with that you know what I
mean and I didn't think it would do what
it did I was up out of my seat I saw a
silhouette of me just
like as you as you elevated I was like
[__] [__] I had tears in my eyes bro I
was I mean the the faces on the audience
all around me some were like oh my God
some were like somewhere in tears I was
literally you would have thought Derrick
Henry just took off for a 98 yard
touchdown run I was losing my mind and
you a vessel that's that's you know be
being a tour whatever being a vessel
like I think when you are that present
and that in tune nobody's more of a
vessel than I think than you jelly you
know I think you really do I think you
inspire so many of us man you know there
just yeah you just have a gift I don't
even know if it's a gift but you be it's
like it's not a gift that you have but
it's just it's a gift that you are right
you know feel like a gift I think to so
many people you know and you know what I
love about you the same dude that could
say something that eloquently just
thought Cameron Haynes was the underwar
guy you know what I'm saying like that's
what makes Theo Theo you know well we're
[__] man a little bit I got a little
bit of
it we all got a little bit of it I I
just um I'm thankful I'm thankful for
both of y'all thank you for letting me
come on this with you guys I'm thank
know both of y'all been great getting to
know you over the last C thanks for
always being somebody that can make
laugh dude and uh you call me too you
check in on me every now and then well
you know why because you make me laugh I
was like [__] I don't feel good I need
to call somebody to make me laugh that's
awesome you were so damn good at it I
had have a choice perfect that was I was
like you did not you were so good at it
I didn't have a choice but like godam
have I let you
down once or tce thankful for your Art
Theo yeah like outside of our friendship
like I'm thankful for your art dude like
I watch the Pod like I'm a fan like I
have been that's what drew me to you is
being I'm one thing I've learned in life
is never be too cool to be a fan you
know what I mean like never be too cool
to be a fan and it's like I'm a fan like
I can tell you like as a brother like I
think you're [__] brilliant and my
cousins man my cousins Addison prope all
the prop my prope family side they love
you they were like girl and her daughter
I saw them breakfast yesterday yeah you
just you did just see them the other day
just seen Ernest and Ryman and Delany at
breakfast I was like that's crazy but uh
no they told me they told me they loved
you and they was like I said I'm going
to see Ernest tomorrow like that's what
he said I was like yeah and they were
like we can't believe you're going with
Theo and like you know my wife I mean we
all just find a lot of lot of you bring
a lot of uh a lot of smiles to people
man and it's like man in a world where
Smiles are so rare where there's no
compassion in America right now there's
no middle ground nobody finds any common
there's so much tension in so many ways
yeah you have found a unique way to
constantly break that and make people
smile and feel really good and man that
is you a gift brother and you need to
know that too if you ain't heard it
recently I'm sure you hear it every day
but I want you to hear it from me
brother you're special man thanks dude I
appreciate it yeah I have sometimes I
have a a tough time feeling proud of
myself you know um and that's okay some
of that's okay because you don't want
your ego to get crazy you know but
sometimes I do have a tough time feeling
proud of myself but um well we're proud
for you for what it's worth I appreciate
that anyone you lack in it we're proud
for you we we were like hype thanks I
got to get you and a wife together it's
like a must yeah I know I know I been
people are always asking me if money's
going to come on or if I'm going to go
on bunnies people ask me a lot so we'll
make it happen this year yeah she had a
she had a clip go viral they kept that
and the meme was the female Theo Von
because she said it was so funny she
said that's garbage she said you know
what that is French for trash it was
like such a g you know and it was like
but yeah y'all would y'all would it
would be cool I got to get y'all
together I'd love for y'all to do the
Podge together Bute to meet yeah I think
it would be fun man um we'll have to do
I'll I'll make sure that I do it with
her in the new year yeah that we'll do
y' y'all will be a lot of fun um and
yeah I think you know even us just
sharing about some of our thoughts and
stuff about each other I think it's just
like and how music is changing I think
it's like there is some evolution in the
way that men communicate and feel and
like you know and need you know need to
be supportive of each other you know I
think I don't know why we're in that
space in a so as a society where it's
like I don't know if it's like that we
used to be all like around the fire in
the woods and we were like right there
for each other like in tribes and small
groups and then now it's there's but
we're there's element some that's
missing you know and so yeah man today
was awesome man just to be able to sit
and kind of you know share and and uh
reflect on the year and uh and yeah and
say something nice about each other you
know it's important because um people
because people need to hear that stuff
you know because sometimes there's
something wrong with us that we can't
say it to ourselves right you know it
just won't the Cy the the the the culde
saac is [__] broken or something you
know for sure so um congratulations man
on great years dude and just on creating
cool stuff and uh to everybody man
praise God man Big Ups Merry Christmas
dude Merry Christmas Happy Holidays
happy holidays yeah happy holidays y'all
get y levels tested huh yeah now I'm
just floating on the breeze and I feel
I'm falling like these leaves I must be
Cornerstone oh but when I reach that
ground I'll share this piece of my life
found I can feel it in my
bones but it's going to
take